When WestJet first took flight in 1996, the vibes were a bit different. People thought denim on denim was peak fashion, inline skates were everywhere, and two out of three women rocked, the Rachel. While those things stayed in the 90s, one thing that hasn't is that fuzzy feeling you get when WestJet welcomes you on board. Here's to WestJetting since 96. Travel back in time with us and actually travel with us at westjet.com slash 30 years. Whether it's with your besties or date night,
当西捷航空于1996年首航时，氛围有些不同。人们认为全身牛仔装是时尚巅峰，轮滑鞋随处可见，三分之二的女性都留着“瑞秋头”。虽然这些事物留在了90年代，但有一件事从未改变，那就是当你登上西捷航空时感受到的那种温馨。为西捷航空自96年以来的飞行干杯。与我们一起穿越回过去，并真正与我们一起在 westjet.com 斜杠 30 years 开启旅程。无论是与闺蜜同行还是约会之夜，
get to all the hottest concerts with Go Transit. Go connects to all the biggest entertainment venues and makes it affordable with special e-ticket fares. A weekend pass offers unlimited travel across the network on any weekend day or holiday for just $10. A weekday group pass offers the same weekday travel flexibility from $30 for two people up to $60 for five. So no matter what day of the week, Go's got you covered. Find out more at gotransit.com slash tickets. Where are my gloves? Come on, heat.
乘坐 Go Transit 前往所有最热门的音乐会。Go 连接所有大型娱乐场所，并通过特别的电子票价使其变得经济实惠。周末通票只需10美元，即可在任何周末或节假日全网无限次乘车。工作日团体通票提供同样的工作日出行灵活性，两人30美元起，五人最高60美元。所以无论一周中的哪一天，Go 都能满足您的需求。在 gotransit.com 斜杠 tickets 了解更多信息。我的手套在哪？来吧，热量。
Winter is hard, but your groceries don't have to be. This winter, stay warm. Tap the banner to order your groceries online at voila.ca. Enjoy in-store prices without leaving your home. You'll find the same regular prices online as in-store. Many promotions are available both in-store and online, though some may vary. We, the Order of the Knights of the Ku Klux Klan, reverentially acknowledged the majesty and supremacy
冬天很难熬，但买菜不必如此。这个冬天，保持温暖。点击横幅在 voila.ca 在线订购您的杂货。足不出户即可享受店内价格。您会在网上找到与店内相同的常规价格。许多促销活动在店内和网上都有，尽管有些可能有所不同。我们，三K党骑士团，虔诚地承认全能上帝的威严和至高无上，
of Almighty God, and recognize His goodness and providence through Jesus Christ, our Lord. Recognizing our relation to the government of the United States of America, we shall ever be devoted to the sublime principles of a pure Americanism and valiant in the defense of its ideals and institutions. We avow the distinction between the races of mankind as decreed by the Creator. And we shall ever be true to the maintenance of white supremacy and strenuously oppose any compromise thereof. We appreciate the value of practical fraternal relationship among men of kindred thought,
并承认祂通过我们的主耶稣基督所展现的仁慈与天意。在承认我们与美利坚合众国政府的关系的同时，我们将永远致力于纯粹的美国主义的崇高原则，并勇敢地捍卫其理想和制度。我们宣称造物主所规定的各人类种族之间的区别。我们将永远忠于维护白人至上主义，并坚决反对任何对此的妥协。我们珍视志同道合者之间实际兄弟关系的价值，
purpose and ideals. And we shall faithfully devote ourselves to the practice of an honorable clannishness that the life of each may be a constant blessing to others. None silver, said Anthar, done in the orlic of His Majesty, the Emperor of the Invisible Empire. Knights of the Ku Klux Klan In the Imperial Palace In the Imperial City of Atlanta Commonwealth of Georgia United States of America
目标和理想。我们将忠实地致力于实践一种光荣的宗派主义，使每个人的生命都能成为对他人的持续祝福。无银，安塔尔说，在无形帝国皇帝陛下的奥利克中完成。三K党骑士团，在亚特兰大帝国城市，佐治亚联邦，美利坚合众国，帝国宫殿内。
This is the 29th day of November Ano Klan 56 So that Dominic was no laughing matter Because it was the creed Spelled with a K of the Ku Klux K as published in the Kloran, again spelt with a K, which was the Constitution and Laws of the Ku Klux Klan Inc instituted in 1922.
这是11月29日，Klan纪年56年。所以那个多米尼克根本不是开玩笑，因为那是三K党的信条（以K开头），正如《Kloran》（同样以K开头）中所发表的那样，这是1922年成立的三K党公司的宪法和法律。
And, I mean, it starts off sounding quite normal and it ends up sounding like something from, I don't know, Star Wars Return of the Phantom Menace or something. And you know the single worst thing about it? Non-silber, said Antha. I mean, what the hell is that? Well, it's apparently it's a mixture of Latin and God. Gothic. And you can't go mixing Latin and Gothic. Well, surely an Ostrogoth might have spoken a mixture of Latin.
而且，我的意思是，它开头听起来很正常，最后听起来却像是来自，我不知道，《星球大战：幽灵的威胁》之类的东西。你知道关于它最糟糕的一点是什么吗？“无银，安塔尔说”。我的意思是，那到底是什么鬼？好吧，显然它是拉丁语和哥特语的混合体。你不能把拉丁语和哥特语混在一起。好吧，东哥特人肯定会说一种拉丁语的混合语。
I don't think so. I mean, you're either speaking one or the other. Come on, make your mind up. Yeah, there's so much to unpack there, actually. Now, last week when we were talking about the clan, we were talking about a paramilitary group that was born in the Reconstruction South, so in the 1860s after the American Civil War. And its purpose was to restore white supremacy in the beaten states of the Confederacy. But, I mean, you said that. was from 1922, that particular issue, edition of the Cloran. So we moved forward a couple of generations. And this is a completely different and truly extraordinary story. So we are in the years of the First World War and afterwards. And this is the story of the second incarnation
我不这么认为。我的意思是，你要么说一种，要么说另一种。得了吧，拿定主意。是的，实际上有很多东西需要拆解。现在，上周当我们谈论三K党时，我们谈论的是一个诞生于重建时期南方，即美国内战后1860年代的准军事组织。其目的是在被击败的邦联各州恢复白人至上。但是，我的意思是，你说那是1922年的，那个特定版本的《Kloran》。所以我们向前推进了几代人。这是一个完全不同且真正非凡的故事。所以我们正处于第一次世界大战及其后的岁月。这就是三K党第二次化身的故事。
of the clan. It was born in Georgia in 1915. And it could not be more different from the first clan. There is a lineage, but they are very different beasts. They're both racist still. They're both racist, of course, but racist in different ways. I think that's something that people often overlook. So their targets are slightly different. So this is not a secretive paramilitary group. This is a fraternal association with between 2 and 5 million members, very public members as well. So is this one more like, say, the Masons than it is the original Ku Klux Klan?
它于1915年诞生于佐治亚州。它与第一个三K党再不同不过了。它们之间有血缘关系，但它们是截然不同的野兽。它们当然仍然是种族主义者，但以不同的方式。我认为这是人们经常忽视的一点。所以它们的目标略有不同。所以这不是一个秘密的准军事组织。这是一个拥有200万到500万成员的兄弟会协会，而且成员非常公开。那么这一个更像是，比如说，共济会，而不是最初的三K党吗？
Much more like the Masons. And we will actually tease that out in this episode. The links between the clan and the Masons. The masons, by the way, were very resentful of the clan coming along and trying to poach its members and were discussed the relationship today. Its greatest popularity, the second clan, was not in the South. It was in the north and in the Midwest. It was in basically the future rust belt of Indiana and Ohio and Pennsylvania and Illinois. It was a product not of slavery in the Civil War, but of advertising and mass entertainment.
更像是共济会。我们实际上会在这一集中探讨这一点。三K党和共济会之间的联系。顺便说一句，共济会对三K党的出现并试图挖走其成员感到非常愤慨，我们今天将讨论这种关系。第二个三K党最受欢迎的地方不是在南方。它是在北部和中西部。它基本上是印第安纳州、俄亥俄州、宾夕法尼亚州和伊利诺伊州未来的铁锈地带的产物。它不是奴隶制和内战的产物，而是广告和大众娱乐的产物。
Absolutely, you said it's still racist. It is still racist. It's very much committed to white supremacy. Those words, white supremacy, are in that creed with a capital K that you read out at the beginning. It copies the hood and the robes from the first clan, but its targets are not, by and large, African Americans, although sometimes they are. But by and large, they are white, Catholics and Jews. They are immigrants and bootleggers. So very different kinds of people.
绝对，你说它仍然是种族主义的。它确实是种族主义的。它非常致力于白人至上主义。那些词，“白人至上”，就在你开头读到的那个以K开头的信条里。它抄袭了第一个三K党的兜帽和长袍，但它的目标大体上不是非裔美国人，尽管有时也是。但大体上，他们是白人、天主教徒和犹太人。他们是移民和私酒贩子。所以是完全不同类型的人。
Because we said it's about wasp supremacy, perhaps, rather than white supremacy. Exactly right, exactly. Now, I already said it's not secretive. It operates in broad daylight. It has adverts in newspapers and magazines. It organizes parades. It organizes massive picnics, barbecues. It appears at state fairs.
因为我们说它可能是关于“WASP（盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒）至上”，而不是白人至上。完全正确，完全正确。现在，我已经说过它不是秘密的。它在大白天运作。它在报纸和杂志上有广告。它组织游行。它组织大型野餐、烧烤。它出现在州博览会上。
Its leaders are an absolutely bizarre group of people. So the first clan was by and large led by local landowners in the south or former Confederate offices and things, the leaders of the second clan are advertising men, marketing men, and this bizarre collection of kind of fraudsters. And its members are small businessmen, they are farmers, and very heavily represented Methodist clergymen, a really important part of the second clan. It even has a women's division which campaigns for greater women's rights, which may kind of strike a lot of listeners as bizarre, including women's political rights. And there is still a lot of vigilante violence with the second clan, and we'll talk about that. But at its peak, it wields
它的领导人是一群绝对怪异的人。所以第一个三K党大体上是由南方的当地地主或前邦联官员等领导的，第二个三K党的领导人是广告商、营销人员，以及这种由骗子组成的怪异集合。它的成员是小商人、农民，以及大量代表的卫理公会牧师，这是第二个三K党非常重要的一部分。它甚至有一个妇女部门，为争取更大的妇女权利而竞选，这可能会让很多听众觉得很怪异，包括妇女的政治权利。第二个三K党仍然有很多治安维持暴力，我们会谈到这一点。但在其鼎盛时期，它拥有
enormous political influence. So in the mid-1920s, the second clan had governors running Indiana, Oklahoma, Oregon, Colorado and Texas. I mentioned Oregon. In Oregon, in the mid-1920s, the majority of all public elected officials are members of the clan. In Colorado, the clan's peak, there was only one city in Colorado, Colorado Springs, that was not run by the Ku Klux Klan. So its rise and fall is an absolutely bizarre story and a brilliant window into 20s America. And it's got some of the sort of strangest and sort of shadiest characters that we've ever done on the rest is history. We should talk about the link with the first clan.
巨大的政治影响力。所以20世纪20年代中期，第二个三K党有州长管理印第安纳州、俄亥俄州、俄克拉荷马州、俄勒冈州、科罗拉多州和德克萨斯州。我提到了俄勒冈州。在20世纪20年代中期的俄勒冈州，大多数公开选举产生的官员都是三K党成员。在科罗拉多州，三K党鼎盛时期，科罗拉多州只有一个城市，科罗拉多斯普林斯，没有被三K党控制。所以它的兴衰是一个绝对怪异的故事，也是了解20年代美国的一扇绝佳窗口。它有一些我们在《历史的其余部分》中做过的最奇怪、最阴暗的角色。我们应该谈谈与第一个三K党的联系。
So let's get into that. And before we do that, I should say, as always when we do American history, but basically because there are so many American historians, there's an enormous historiography of this kind of stuff. So there's some brilliant books, which I've relied on by people like David Chalmers and Linda Gordon, Thomas Pigram. The trouble is they all disagree with each other. So that's something of a scholarly minefield. So I've tried to pick my way through it as best I can. But everybody agrees that basically the second clan starts with a novelist. I said it was born of entertainment and it is. I mean, that's such a so striking, isn't it? Because Gone with the Wind, Margaret
那么让我们进入正题。在此之前，我应该说，正如我们做美国历史时一贯的那样，但基本上因为有太多的美国历史学家，这种东西有大量的史学研究。所以有一些我依赖的杰出书籍，作者如大卫·查尔默斯、琳达·戈登、托马斯·皮格拉姆。问题是他们彼此不同意。所以这在学术上是一个雷区。所以我尽量从中摸索出一条路。但每个人都同意，基本上第二个三K党始于一位小说家。我说它是娱乐的产物，确实如此。我的意思是，这太引人注目了，不是吗？因为玛格丽特·米切尔的小说《飘》
Mitchell's novel, plays a similar role. It's a novel that then inspires a film. And this is the same story, kind of what, 20 years before? Yes, exactly. A novel actually about the same kind of thing, really. So the novelist this time is a man called Thomas Dixon. Dixon was born in North Carolina in 1864. His father was a local Baptist minister and a landowner and a slaveholder. And both his father and his uncle were clan members when he was young.
扮演了类似的角色。这是一部激发了电影灵感的小说。这和20年前的故事是一样的，对吧？是的，完全正确。实际上是一部关于同样事情的小说，真的。所以这次的小说家是一个叫托马斯·迪克森的人。迪克森于1864年出生在北卡罗来纳州。他的父亲是一位当地的浸信会牧师、地主和奴隶主。当他年轻时，他的父亲和叔叔都是三K党成员。
And Dixon said later that his earliest memory was a clan parade through the village streets in Shelby, North Carolina when he was five. He also claimed to remember an incident when a woman came to their house. She was the widow of a Confederate soldier. And she said a black man had attacked and raped her daughter. And to help her, the clan hanged this man publicly in the town square. This is the story that Dixon tells anyway, whether this actually happened. It's a different matter.
迪克森后来声称，他最早的记忆是五岁时在北卡罗来纳州谢尔比的村庄街道上进行的三K党游行。他还声称记得有一次一个女人来到他们家。她是邦联士兵的遗孀。她说一个黑人袭击并强奸了她的女儿。为了帮助她，三K党在城镇广场公开绞死了这个男人。这就是迪克森讲述的故事，无论这是否真的发生过。这是另一回事。
Anyway, Dixon, he grows up in North Carolina. He's an unbelievably tall man. He's kind of six foot six or something. crazy. He's really tall. He's a brilliant student. He goes to Johns Hopkins University in Baltimore, which was then the outstanding graduate school in the country. And he studied politics. And he became friends with a young man from Virginia who was in his class called Woodrow Wilson. Both of them really interested in politics. Wilson obviously does incredibly well at it. Dixon also starts off doing really well. He becomes a local legislature in North Carolina
无论如何，迪克森在北卡罗来纳州长大。他是一个高得不可思议的人。他大概六英尺六英寸左右。太疯狂了。他真的很高。他是一个聪明的学生。他去了巴尔的摩的约翰霍普金斯大学，那是当时国内杰出的研究生院。他学习政治。他与班上一位来自弗吉尼亚州的年轻人成为了朋友，名叫伍德罗·威尔逊。他们俩都对政治非常感兴趣。威尔逊显然做得非常出色。迪克森起初也做得很好。他成为了北卡罗来纳州的当地立法者，
when he's just 20, when he's actually too young to vote, he has a seat in the legislature. So he's like William Hague. Yes. Your friend, William Hague. Big fan of the rest of his history, William Hague. That's all I'm going to say. Great man. Yeah, big fan.
那时他才20岁，实际上还不到投票年龄，他就已经在立法机构中占有一席之地了。所以他就像威廉·黑格。是的。你的朋友，威廉·黑格。《历史的其余部分》的忠实粉丝，威廉·黑格。这就是我要说的。伟人。是的，忠实粉丝。
Now, he can't stick to anything. He becomes a lawyer, then he becomes a Baptist minister. He becomes an evangelical speaker, and he's brilliant at that. Does that for a while. Then he decides to become a public lecturer, and he goes around giving lectures about the South and about the loss cause of the Confederacy and about the evils of reconstruction. He claims to oppose slavery, doesn't he? Yeah.
现在，他什么都坚持不下去。他成为了一名律师，然后成为了一名浸信会牧师。他成为了一名福音派演讲者，而且非常出色。做了那段时间。然后他决定成为一名公众演讲者，他到处发表演讲，谈论南方、邦联的“迷途事业”以及重建的罪恶。他声称反对奴隶制，不是吗？是的。
But it's as someone who opposes slavery, kind of posture. It's exactly that. It goes all in. Yes. Why I, as a Remainer, think Brexit was the best thing that ever happened. That's exactly what it is. I'm very familiar with that particular line of journalistic activity. I know you are.
但作为一个反对奴隶制的人，这是一种姿态。正是如此。他全力以赴。是的。为什么我作为一个留欧派，认为英国脱欧是发生过的最好的事情。这正是它的样子。我对那种特定的新闻活动非常熟悉。我知道你是。
That's why I mentioned it. So then he decides, unlike me, he decides, to try his hand at writing novels. And he wrote a novel in 1902 called The Leopard Spots, which was an account of reconstruction in which he basically was saying, a leopard can't change its spots. And by that, he meant African Americans can't change their spots either, as in, you know, once a slave, always a slave, as it were.
这就是我提到它的原因。所以然后他决定，不像我，他决定尝试写小说。他在1902年写了一部名为《豹斑》的小说，这是对重建时期的描述，他在其中基本上是在说，豹子改不了它的斑点。他的意思是，非裔美国人也改不了他们的斑点，就像，你知道，一旦是奴隶，永远是奴隶。
And then in 1905, he wrote another book called The Clansman, a Klansman with a C, not a K. So he's made an interesting choice there. Well, that's because he's been to a top graduate school. So he knows how to spell. Yeah, that's it. I should have thought of that. So the Klansman, the subtitle is a historical romance of the Ku Klux Klan.
然后在1905年，他写了另一本书叫《三K党人》（Clansman），用C拼写，而不是K。所以他在那里做了一个有趣的选择。好吧，那是因为他去过顶尖的研究生院。所以他知道怎么拼写。是的，就是这样。我本该想到这一点的。所以《三K党人》，副标题是“三K党的历史浪漫史”。
And basically, it's a terrible book. It's the story of two families, the Cameron's and the Stonemans. One fights for the north, the other fights for the south. The hero is called Ben Cameron. He fought for the South, and he ends up leading the local clan. And he's in love with a lovely pouting maiden called Elsie Stoneman, who unfortunately is from the bad family. Because her father, Austin Stoneman, is an evil Republican, a radical.
基本上，这是一本糟糕的书。这是两个家庭的故事，卡梅伦一家和斯通曼一家。一个为北方而战，另一个为南方而战。英雄叫本·卡梅伦。他为南方而战，最终领导了当地的三K党。他爱上了一个可爱的、嘟着嘴的少女，名叫埃尔西·斯通曼，不幸的是，她来自那个坏家庭。因为她的父亲，奥斯汀·斯通曼，是一个邪恶的共和党人，一个激进分子。
He's plotting to hand over the South to a massive mob of African-American rapists. That's basically the story. As this might suggest, the Klansman is an intensely racist book. And the racism is not a sort of bug. It's not a side thing. It's the essence of the story. The racism runs right through it. The most famous scene in it is where Ben's sister Flora is being menaced by this crazed black freedman,
他正密谋把南方交给一大群非裔美国强奸犯。这基本上就是故事。正如这可能暗示的那样，这是一本极其种族主义的书。种族主义不是一种“漏洞”。这不是次要的事情。它是故事的本质。种族主义贯穿始终。其中最著名的场景是本的妹妹弗洛拉被这个疯狂的黑人自由民威胁，
who wants to rape her and she throws us off off a cliff. And anyway, Ben and his pals put on their white robes and their hoods and they ride off to exact revenge and to redeem the South. Now, even at the time, a lot of people saw this as a very shocking book. You know, they thought it was incendiary, outrageous, a distortion of history and all of this. It was massively popular. It sold 100,000 copies. Dixon made it into a play, and he cast himself in the lead.
他想强奸她，她把自己从悬崖上扔了下去。无论如何，本和他的伙伴们穿上他们的白色长袍和兜帽，骑马去复仇并拯救南方。现在，即使在当时，很多人也认为这是一本非常令人震惊的书。你知道，他们认为这是煽动性的、令人愤慨的、对历史的歪曲等等。它非常受欢迎。它卖出了10万册。迪克森把它改编成了一部戏剧，并亲自担任主角。
Didn't you not do that when you were a student? Did you not cast yourself? I did, yes. The parallels are uncanny. Well, the thing is, people used to say of him, he'll never make it as an actor because he's too tall. He's so tall that people can't take him seriously on stage. He could play Jack and the Beanstalk. He'd be good in that.
你当学生的时候没做过吗？你没把自己选为主角吗？我做了，是的。相似之处令人毛骨悚然。好吧，问题是，人们过去常说他，他永远不会成为一名演员，因为他太高了。他太高了，以至于人们在舞台上无法认真对待他。他可以演《杰克与魔豆》。他在那里面会很棒。
Well, he could play the Beanstalk. Going to Panto. Yeah, I suppose so. Anyway, the play was banned in some cities for causing public disorder. there were reports that after performances, white mobs would go rampaging to the streets, that they would be a kind of spike in lynchings and whatnot. The Washington Post in 1906 wrote an absolutely savage article about the play.
好吧，他可以演那棵豆茎。去演哑剧。是的，我想是这样。无论如何，这部戏在一些城市被禁演，因为它引起了公共骚乱。有报道称，演出结束后，白人暴徒会在街上横冲直撞，私刑事件会激增等等。《华盛顿邮报》在1906年写了一篇关于这部戏的极其尖刻的文章。
The play does not possess even the merit of historical truth. It excites the passions and prejudices of the dominant class at the expense of the defenseless minority. In the present condition of the public mind in the South, it's a firebrand, a council of barbarity, in fact, a crime. So it's not true that at the time people, you know, sort of took this stuff. A lot of people were very shocked by it. So then along came the most brilliant cinema director in America, a man called D.W. Griffith. Hollywood, remember, is just a
这部戏甚至不具备历史真实的优点。它以牺牲无助的少数群体为代价，激发了统治阶级的激情和偏见。在南方公众心态的当前状况下，它是一个火种，一个野蛮的建议，实际上是一种犯罪。所以当时人们并没有，你知道，接受这些东西，这不是真的。很多人对此感到非常震惊。所以然后出现了美国最杰出的电影导演，一个叫D.W.格里菲斯的人。好莱坞，记住，此时才
couple of years old at this point. Now, Griffith is from Kentucky. His father had also served in the Confederate Army, and he shared Dixon's view of the Civil War and Reconstruction. And he basically bought Dixon's play, and he said, I'm going to make it into a film. He offered Dixon 25% of the profits, and the result was probably the most influential and important feature film that has ever been made. Wow, that is a high claim. The foundational film in the history of cinema. The first true long-running feature film with a long narrative that goes on over 12 reels,
几岁。现在，格里菲斯来自肯塔基州。他的父亲也曾在邦联军队服役，他认同迪克森对内战和重建的看法。他基本上买下了迪克森的戏剧，他说，我要把它拍成电影。他给了迪克森25%的利润，结果这可能是史上最具影响力和最重要的故事片。哇，这是一个很高的评价。电影史上的奠基之作。第一部真正长篇的故事片，有着长达12卷的叙事，
so it goes on for between two or three hours, depending how quickly you project the film, because it's an old-fashioned kind of silent film. It cost what was then a record $100,000, the birth of a nation. It was released in February 1915. Even the soundtrack was groundbreaking because it has lots of classical music. Most obviously, Wagner's The Ride of the Valkyrus, which plays as the Ku Klux Klan are charging out in their white robes and hoods. And film historians generally agree,
所以它持续了两个到三个小时，取决于你放映电影的速度，因为它是一种老式的默片。它耗资当时创纪录的10万美元，《一个国家的诞生》。它于1915年2月上映。甚至配乐也是开创性的，因为它有很多古典音乐。最明显的是瓦格纳的《女武神的骑行》，当三K党穿着白色长袍和兜帽冲出来时，音乐响起。电影历史学家普遍认为，
this is the film that establishes the template for so much that follows. It's the film that prefigures. I don't know, Lawrence of Arabia, Ben Hur, gladiator, the Lord of the Rings and so on and so forth. It's transformative in the way that people make movies. It attracted an enormous crowd, so 3 million people in New York City saw this film. So Dixon's absolutely quits in with his quarter of the profit. They make loads of money from this film. And at the end, there are stories that basically when the Vargas is playing
这是确立了后续许多电影模板的电影。它是预示了，我不知道，《阿拉伯的劳伦斯》、《宾虚》、《角斗士》、《指环王》等等的电影。它在人们制作电影的方式上具有变革性。它吸引了巨大的人群，所以纽约市有300万人看了这部电影。所以迪克森用他的四分之一利润绝对退出了。他们从这部电影中赚了很多钱。最后，有故事说基本上当瓦格纳的音乐响起时，
and the clan are riding out, waving their swords to overpower the kind of mobs of freedmen and to redeem the South for white supremacy. There were stories that audiences would be on their feet. There would be people cheering and sobbing. I mean, don't forget, it's the first time anybody has ever seen anything remotely like this. So they are blown away by it. It is amazing that the two great epics of American cinema in the first half of the 20th century, this and gone with the wind, are both basic.
三K党骑马冲出，挥舞着剑去压制那些自由民暴徒，并为白人至上主义拯救南方。有故事说观众会站起来。会有人欢呼和啜泣。我的意思是，别忘了，这是任何人第一次看到类似这样的东西。所以他们被它震撼了。令人惊奇的是，20世纪上半叶美国电影的两大史诗，这部和《飘》，基本上都是
promoting this kind of fantasy of the of the civil war in its aftermath. It is. It is incredible, isn't it? Well, it tells you something about American culture. I mean, that's not all American culture is, of course, but it tells you about the appeal of the lost cause myth, how deeply it's embedded by this point. And how in a very urban society that's become the crucible of modernity, how this appeal to a kind of backward-looking, nostalgic, pastoral, you know, frankly, and intensely
在推广这种关于内战及其后果的幻想。是的。这真是不可思议，不是吗？好吧，它告诉你一些关于美国文化的事情。我的意思是，当然，这并不是美国文化的全部，但它告诉你关于“迷途事业”神话的吸引力，它在这一点上是多么根深蒂固。以及在一个已经成为现代性熔炉的非常城市化的社会中，这种对一种向后看、怀旧、田园、你知道，坦率地说，极其
racist view of history, how that appeals to people. The nostalgia is a really important element of it, I think. I suppose also the potency of presenting yourself as an underdog in such a situation. Yeah. Because, you know, if you're the underdog and you cast yourself as oppressed, then you are entitled to inflict violence. And violence is always cinematic. Yeah, agreed.
种族主义的历史观的诉求，它是如何吸引人们的。我认为怀旧是其中一个非常重要的因素。我想还有在这种情况把自己表现为弱者的效力。是的。因为，你知道，如果你是弱者，你把自己塑造成受压迫者，那么你就有权施加暴力。而暴力总是具有电影感的。是的，同意。
Agreed. I mean, both of these, in both films, there's a sense of victimhood, isn't there? We are the big victims in all this. Completely, yeah. Now, as with the novel, the film provoked. enormous controversy at the time. Civil rights groups like the National Association for the Advancement of Coloured People, the NAACP, organised protests and boycotts. Some northern cities did try to ban it, but it was a massive success. So it was the biggest grossing film until gone with
同意。我的意思是，这两部电影中，都有受害者心态，不是吗？我们是这一切中的大受害者。完全是，是的。现在，正如小说一样，这部电影在当时引发了巨大的争议。像全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）这样的民权组织组织了抗议和抵制。一些北方城市确实试图禁止它，但它取得了巨大的成功。所以它是票房最高的电影，直到《飘》
the wind. It's up there with Avatar and Titanic and the other kind of all-time box office blockbusters. And it had the implicit endorsement of the most powerful man in the country, because Dixon's mate, Woodrow Wilson, is now president. And he agreed to a private, White House showing of the birth of a nation, it became the first film ever to be shown in the White House. And is that because he's mates with Dixon? Or because he's interested in the topic? I think it's probably three things. One, it's a massive, it's a cultural landmark in a way that no film up to this point has ever been. Number two, it's because he's friends with Dixon. And number three, it's because he's passionately interested in the material. So Wilson's own book,
出现。它与《阿凡达》和《泰坦尼克号》以及其他那种史上票房大片并列。它得到了国内最有权势的人的默许，因为迪克森的伙伴，伍德罗·威尔逊，现在是总统。他同意在白宫私人放映《一个国家的诞生》，它成为有史以来第一部在白宫放映的电影。这是因为他和迪克森是朋友吗？还是因为他对这个话题感兴趣？我认为可能是三件事。第一，这是一个巨大的文化地标，在这一点上没有任何电影能与之相比。第二，因为他是迪克森的朋友。第三，因为他热衷于这些材料。所以威尔逊自己的书，
Don't forget Woodrow Wilson had been an academic. His own history of the American people is quoted in the film. In the kind of, you know, they have title cards because it's a silent film. So these words, adventurers swarmed out of the north to cousin beguile and use the Negroes. The white men were roused by a mere instinct of self-preservation until at last there had sprung into existence a great Ku Klux Klan, a veritable empire of the South, to protect the southern country. So it's quoting Wilson here. you know, provingly, his book.
别忘了伍德罗·威尔逊曾是一名学者。他自己的《美国人民史》在电影中被引用。在那种，你知道，他们有字幕卡，因为它是默片。所以这些话，“冒险家从北方蜂拥而出，去欺骗、诱惑和利用黑人。白人被一种纯粹的自我保护本能所唤醒，直到最后出现了一个伟大的三K党，一个真正的南方帝国，来保护南方国家。”所以这里引用了威尔逊的话。你知道，赞许地，他的书。
And Wilson, the line that's attributed to him, it is like writing history with lightning. And my only regret is that it is all so terribly true. So this is what you always read that Wilson said. Actually, that quotation didn't appear until the 1930s after Wilson was dead. But some historians say, it's a phrase that Wilson did use, history written by lightning. He used it in other contexts.
而威尔逊，归功于他的那句话，“这就像用闪电书写历史。我唯一的遗憾是这一切都太可怕地真实了。”所以这就是你总是读到威尔逊所说的话。实际上，那句引语直到1930年代威尔逊死后才出现。但一些历史学家说，这是威尔逊确实使用过的一个短语，“用闪电书写的历史”。他在其他语境中使用过它。
And it sounds like the kind of thing he would have said. Anyway, Dixon was thrilled that Wilson had given it his approval. He wrote to Wilson a few months later, This play is transforming the entire population of the North and the West into sympathetic southern voters. And he's not necessarily wrong because, as we shall see, you know, the film does play a part in the creation of a second clan. Because one of the people who goes to see the film is another southerner called William Joseph Simmons. Now, Simmons is a generation younger than the people we've been talking about. So he's from Alabama.
听起来像是他会说的那种话。无论如何，迪克森对威尔逊给予它的认可感到非常激动。几个月后他写信给威尔逊，“这部戏正在将北方和西方的全体人口转变为同情的南方选民。”他并不一定错了，因为正如我们将看到的，你知道，这部电影确实在第二个三K党的创建中发挥了作用。因为去看这部电影的人之一是另一个南方人，名叫威廉·约瑟夫·西蒙斯。现在，西蒙斯比我们一直在谈论的人年轻一代。所以他来自阿拉巴马州。
He grew up in a world where the clan is quite a distant memory. He grew up in a world where the South has been to use the jargon redeemed for white supremacy. So black rights have been eroded and reconstruction is long gone. His father was a doctor and his father died when he was young and he idolized his father. And he would tell stories, rose-tinted stories about how his father had been in the clan back in the day and all of this kind of thing. Simmons fancies himself as an adventurer, and he, at the age of 18,
他在一个三K党只是遥远记忆的世界里长大。他在一个南方已经，用行话来说，为了白人至上主义而“被拯救”的世界里长大。所以黑人的权利被侵蚀了，重建早已结束。他的父亲是一名医生，在他年轻时就去世了，他崇拜他的父亲。他会讲故事，玫瑰色的故事，关于他的父亲过去是如何在三K党里的，以及所有这类事情。西蒙斯自认为是冒险家，他在18岁时，
enlists to fight in Cuba, in the Spanish-American War. But he arrives too late to see action, and he therefore has to invent a fantasy world in which he had fought bravely and all of this kind of thing. Actually, if you Google him, he looks like a sort of a small town lawyer from Northamptonshire.
报名参加在古巴的战斗，参加美西战争。但他到达得太晚，没能参加战斗，因此他不得不编造一个幻想世界，在其中他英勇作战等等。实际上，如果你谷歌他，他看起来像是一个来自北安普敦郡的小镇律师。
He looks just unbelievably not. nondescript and uninteresting. Oh, he looks like a country doctor. He looks like a really, really mediocre country doctor. Okay. So he tried his hand as Dixon had at the church, and he became a Methodist preacher in the sort of the backwoods of Alabama and Florida. But he was useless.
他看起来简直不可思议地平庸且无趣。哦，他看起来像个乡村医生。他看起来像个非常、非常平庸的乡村医生。好吧。所以他像迪克森一样尝试了教会，他成为了阿拉巴马州和佛罗里达州偏远地区的卫理公会传教士。但他没用。
He got into debt. And in fact, the church kicked him out in 1912 for, and I quote, inefficiency and moral impairment. I don't really know what that means. No one knows what that means. But anyway, not good. He then inevitably became.
他负债累累。事实上，教会因为，我引用，“效率低下和道德败坏”在1912年把他踢了出去。我真的不知道那是什么意思。没人知道那是什么意思。但无论如何，不好。他然后不可避免地成为了。
I'm a garter salesman. There's a lot of salesmen in the story. Brilliant. To ladies or to men? I think to ladies, surely. Anyway, Simmons, this guy with his glasses, he finds his vocation eventually in the 1910s. He is a fraternal organiser. Now, fraternalism is absolutely central to this story.
一名吊带袜推销员。这个故事里有很多推销员。太棒了。是对女士还是对男士？我想是对女士，肯定。无论如何，西蒙斯，这个戴眼镜的家伙，最终在1910年代找到了他的职业。他是一名兄弟会组织者。现在，兄弟会主义在这个故事中是绝对核心的。
And a lot of people may be like, what is this? Fraternalism is basically about clubs and hobbyist groups. and association to various kinds. So because America is a country of immigrants and newcomers, it's also a country of clubs. They love a club and the association and a neighbourhood community group and all of the kind of things that we in Britain, by and large, I think sneer at and turn up our noses at. Do you not think, Tom? No, we're a clubbable people. We have, you know, with our love of carrier pigeon racing and rolls and all that kind of thing.
很多人可能会想，这是什么？兄弟会主义基本上是关于俱乐部和业余爱好团体。以及各种协会。所以因为美国是一个移民和新来者的国家，它也是一个俱乐部国家。他们喜欢俱乐部、协会、社区团体，以及我们在英国大体上我认为会嘲笑和嗤之以鼻的所有那些事情。你不觉得吗，汤姆？不，我们是一个喜欢俱乐部的民族。我们有，你知道，我们对赛信鸽和草地滚球的热爱等等。
decade are you in? Well, I'm in the 1920s. Yeah, I guess so, maybe. I think there's probably more drinking in Britain. That's true, but, you know, sports clubs and all that kind of. Anyway, six million Americans by the turn of the 20th century had joined club fraternal orders, as they're called. Yeah, I mean, okay, so the difference between us and America, we are less keen on clubs with mad names. Yeah. Yeah, so you rightly say the club that you would join it's a pigeon fancying club or a crown green bowls club. You wouldn't join a club called the Knights of Pithyass or something. Do you know, I would, but I suspect most people wouldn't.
你在哪个年代？好吧，我在20世纪20年代。是的，我想是这样，也许。我认为英国的饮酒可能更多。那是真的，但是，你知道，体育俱乐部等等。无论如何，到20世纪之交，有600万美国人加入了俱乐部兄弟会，正如他们所称的那样。是的，我的意思是，好吧，所以我们和美国之间的区别，我们对名字古怪的俱乐部不太热衷。是的。是的，所以你正确地说，你会加入的俱乐部是信鸽俱乐部或草地滚球俱乐部。你不会加入一个叫“皮提亚斯骑士团”之类的俱乐部。你知道吗，我会，但我怀疑大多数人不会。
You still can, and you haven't. You have not joined such a club. Is it still going? Almost certainly. Are you a member of the odd fellows? No. Are you remember the Freemasons? I suppose you wouldn't say if you were.
你仍然可以，但你没有。你没有加入这样的俱乐部。它还在运作吗？几乎可以肯定。你是“奇人会”（Odd Fellows）的成员吗？不。你是共济会的成员吗？我想如果你是，你也不会说。
No, I'm not, but you're right. I wouldn't say if I was. You hesitated and that was, I thought fuck you away. Are you remember the ancient order of United Workman? Yeah, of course, we all are. I mean, who isn't? So all of these clubs were set up, and they basically appealed to you because you're a respectable person. You want to be respectable.
不，我不是，但你是对的。如果我是，我也不会说。你犹豫了，我想那是……你是“联合工人古老秩序”的成员吗？是的，当然，我们都是。我的意思是，谁不是呢？所以所有这些俱乐部都是建立起来的，它们基本上吸引你，因为你是一个受人尊敬的人。你想受人尊敬。
You want a network. You're a patriot. You like your fellow men. You want to join the Knights of Pithias and shake hands with the bloke who sells insurance in Monroeville, Idaho, a place I've just made up. I want to go on a voyage in an ancient galley to Britain. Well, nobody from Idaho is ever going to do that. No, I suppose not. So Simmons joins 15 of these groups.
你想要一个网络。你是一个爱国者。你喜欢你的同胞。你想加入皮提亚斯骑士团，和那个在爱达荷州门罗维尔卖保险的家伙握手，那是我刚编出来的地方。我想去英国进行一次古代帆船航行。好吧，没有爱达荷州的人会那样做。不，我想不会。所以西蒙斯加入了15个这样的团体。
He joins, I think it was too many. He joins the Masons. He joins some veterans groups from the Spanish-D-American War in which he barely featured at all. He joins lots of churches, different Baptist churches. He loves it. He can't get enough for this. Is this like fraternities in universities? Well, they have stupid Greek names, don't they?
他加入了，我想太多了。他加入了共济会。他加入了一些美西战争的退伍军人团体，他在其中几乎没有参与。他加入了许多教会，不同的浸信会。他喜欢它。他对此乐此不疲。这就像大学里的兄弟会吗？好吧，它们有愚蠢的希腊名字，不是吗？
Is it kind of offering the same kind of thing, the sense? that, you know, it's not just about meeting people, but also giving each other, you know, scratching each other's backs and things. I think so. Simmons's favorite fraternity, or whatever they're called, fraternal organization, it's called the Woodmen of the World. And that was founded in Nebraska. That was founded in Nebraska in 1890.
它是否提供同样的东西，那种感觉？就是，你知道，这不仅仅是关于结识人，也关于互相，你知道，互相抓背之类的。我想是这样。西蒙斯最喜欢的兄弟会，或者无论他们叫什么，兄弟会组织，叫“世界木工”。那是1890年在内布拉斯加州成立的。
And it was inspired by the idea of pioneers hewing wood. I mean, it sounds rubbish. And he raises to become a colonel in the woodmen. So that's why people. call him Colonel Simmons. He allows people to think that he's called a colonel because there is heroism in the Spanish-American War. Actually, no, he's a colonel because it was a made-up title from the woodmen of the world. And so he basically was a district manager, that regional sales manager. And he has the idea of launching his own fraternal organization to make money.
它的灵感来自于先驱者砍木头的想法。我的意思是，这听起来很垃圾。他升到了木工组织里的上校。所以这就是为什么人们叫他西蒙斯上校。他让人们认为他被称为上校是因为在美西战争中有英雄主义。实际上，不，他是上校是因为那是来自世界木工的一个编造的头衔。所以他基本上是一个地区经理，即区域销售经理。他有了创办自己的兄弟会组织来赚钱的想法。
This is basically going to be the reborn clan. And he claimed that as a young man or as a boy, he'd had a vision of Klansmen and horseback kind of riding across his bedroom wall. But this is almost certainly rubbish. What probably happened was he saw this film and he thought, God, people love this. You know, when the Vagnes playing and everyone's dressed up in their white robes, there are people in the audience sobbing with joy. I should found a club and get them all to dress up like this. And I reckon I could make a lot of money.
这基本上将是重生的三K党。他声称作为一个年轻人或男孩，他曾有过三K党骑马穿过他卧室墙壁的幻象。但这几乎肯定是垃圾。可能发生的是他看了这部电影，他想，上帝，人们喜欢这个。你知道，当瓦格纳的音乐响起，每个人都穿着白色长袍时，观众席里有人喜极而泣。我应该创办一个俱乐部，让他们都这样打扮。我想我能赚很多钱。
And he was hit by a car one day. He spent three months, basically, laid up in bed. During those three months, he decided to make up the rules for this new group, and he copyrighted them. The fact that he copyrighted them says to me, he's only interested in one thing, which is cash, which is getting money out of this. Anyway, he goes to all his former, you know, all his other clubs that he's a member of, and he persuades some of his friends, about two dozen of them, to join his new group.
有一天他被车撞了。他花了三个月，基本上，躺在床上。在那三个月里，他决定为这个新团体制定规则，并为它们申请了版权。他为它们申请版权的事实告诉我，他只对一件事感兴趣，那就是现金，就是从这里弄钱。无论如何，他去找他所有的前，你知道，他所属的所有其他俱乐部，并说服他的一些朋友，大约两打人，加入他的新团体。
And he says, meet me at Thanksgiving Eve at the Piedmont, hotel in Atlanta, Georgia. So they meet this hotel, and he has hired a sightseeing bus. And they all get on this bus. Americans hate buses. Well, some of them refused to get on. They said it was too cold, and they wouldn't come. And so they missed out on the launch of the second plan.
他说，感恩节前夕在佐治亚州亚特兰大的皮埃蒙特酒店见我。所以他们在酒店见面，他租了一辆观光巴士。他们都上了这辆巴士。美国人讨厌巴士。好吧，有些人拒绝上车。他们说太冷了，他们不会来。所以他们错过了第二个三K党的发布。
And they head out to the city on this sightseeing tour bus to Stone Mountain, which is outside Atlanta. And today, Stone Mountain is notorious. It's the Confederate Rushmore, because some would put a bloke carved on the side. side of the mountain. Pictures of Jefferson Davis, I think, Robert E. Lee and Stonewall Jackson. So if you're a kind of lost cause person, you go there at a pilgrimage. Anyway, that didn't exist back then.
他们乘坐这辆观光巴士前往亚特兰大郊外的石山。今天，石山臭名昭著。它是邦联的拉什莫尔山，因为有人把一个家伙雕刻在山的一侧。我想是杰斐逊·戴维斯、罗伯特·E·李和石墙杰克逊的照片。所以如果你是一个“迷途事业”的人，你会去那里朝圣。无论如何，那时不存在。
Simmons has built an altar on the top of the mountain, most stones, and he's made a cross of pine boards, and he's drenched the cross with kerosene, and he sets it to light, so there's a burning cross. And as he put it himself, under a blazing, fiery torch, the invisible empire was cold from its slumber of half a century. God. I mean, that really is Star Wars. It is, yeah, but the thing is,
西蒙斯在山顶建了一个祭坛，大部分是石头，他用松木板做了一个十字架，他用煤油浸透了十字架，并点燃了它，所以有一个燃烧的十字架。正如他自己所说，在炽热的火炬下，无形帝国从半个世纪的沉睡中被唤醒。上帝。我的意思是，那真的是《星球大战》。是的，确实，但问题是，
the original clan never burned crosses. This is made up. This was made up by Dixon in his book, by Dixon in his novel. And then Griffith turns it, puts it on screen in the birth of a nation, and people think, God, that looks brilliant.
最初的三K党从不焚烧十字架。这是编造的。这是迪克森在他的书中，迪克森在他的小说中编造的。然后格里菲斯把它变成了电影，把它放在《一个国家的诞生》的屏幕上，人们想，上帝，那看起来太棒了。
And that's why this bloke, Simmons, has copied it. So it's fantasy-creating reality. It is. It's total cosplaying. It is complete cosplaying. And a week later, he puts an advert in an Atlanta,
这就是为什么这个叫西蒙斯的家伙抄袭了它。所以这是幻想创造现实。是的。这是完全的Cosplay。这是彻底的Cosplay。一周后，他在亚特兰大的一份报纸上登了一则广告，
newspaper. This gives you a sense of the seriousness of this organization. A classy order of the highest class. Who was, would you like to join a classy order? Oh, that sounds really classy. And for men of intelligence and character. So basically, in the next few years, a dribble of people join this organization. It's not even really a white supremacist organization, or rather, It's white supremacist in the sense that, you know, a lot of these fraternal organizations in somewhere like Georgia, if they appeal to white men, you can bet your bottom dollar that most of those white men will be white supremacists because it's so common. I think if you're taking the name and dressing up as people who were a racist organization, I think that's baked in. Of course. Yes.
这让你感受到了这个组织的严肃性。一个最高级的阶级秩序。谁是，你想加入一个高级阶级吗？哦，那听起来真的很高级。而且是为有智慧和品格的男人准备的。所以基本上，在接下来的几年里，一小部分人加入了这个组织。它甚至不是一个真正的白人至上主义组织，或者更确切地说，它是白人至上主义的，因为，你知道，在佐治亚州这样的地方，如果它们吸引白人，你可以打赌那些白人中的大多数会是白人至上主义者，因为这太普遍了。我认为如果你采用这个名字并打扮成一个种族主义组织的人，我认为那是根深蒂固的。当然。是的。
Nobody who joins this organization says, actually, I felt like the North had a point. point in the Civil War. Yeah, of course, by definition, it's going to appeal to people of a particular kind. However, there's no sense that they're going to start riding around and lynching people. They're just basically dressing up and mouthing gibberish to each other. And basically, Simmons attracts about 90 members and he spends most of his time trying to sell them life insurance. Are there any ladies at this point?
没有加入这个组织的人会说，实际上，我觉得北方在内战中是有道理的。是的，当然，根据定义，它会吸引特定类型的人。然而，没有迹象表明他们会开始骑马到处去私刑处死人。他们基本上只是打扮起来，互相嘟囔着胡言乱语。基本上，西蒙斯吸引了大约90名成员，他大部分时间都在试图向他们推销人寿保险。这时候有女士吗？
No. So his gartes are selling business. No. No opportunities. I see that's a missed opportunity there. So anyway, what then transforms his prospect? In 1917, the United States enters the First World War. And there's a huge sort of search of patriotism, but also anxiety.
没有。所以他的吊带袜推销业务。没有。没有机会。我看到那是一个错失的机会。所以无论如何，是什么改变了他的前景？1917年，美国参加了第一次世界大战。有一种巨大的爱国主义浪潮，但也有一种焦虑。
Great fears of subversives and socialists and immigrants and radicals and whatnot. And this is going to culminate in 1919 in the first great red scare. Sort of great panic about Bolsheviks, about labor unions, about strikes, all of this kind of thing. Simmons makes a very feeble attempt to cash in on this. There was a thing called the American Protective League, which was basically sponsored by the federal government, a sort of volunteer organization, organized by the Department of Justice, to spy on subversives, German spies in our midst. Simmons went along and said, we'd like to help. And they said, you're too small, you're just a joke of an outfit.
对颠覆分子、社会主义者、移民、激进分子等等的极大恐惧。这一切将在1919年达到顶峰，演变成第一次红色恐慌。这是一种关于布尔什维克、工会、罢工等各种事物的巨大恐慌。西蒙斯试图利用这一点，但尝试非常无力。当时有一个叫“美国保护联盟”的组织，基本上是由联邦政府资助的，是一个由司法部组织的志愿者组织，旨在监视颠覆分子和潜伏在我们中间的德国间谍。西蒙斯主动提出想要帮忙，但他们说：“你们太小了，你们的组织简直是个笑话。”
We don't need you. So we get to 1920, the war is over. and Simmons has still failed to capitalize on what would seem like a very promising kind of mood. So people are very anxious about the enemy within. And his clan, you know, at the most he's got a couple of hundred members, probably fewer than 100 hardcore members in Georgia, maybe a few in Alabama. And in desperation, he goes to see some PR people. And this is a couple called Edward Young Clark and Elizabeth Tyler,
“我们不需要你们。”时间到了1920年，战争结束了。西蒙斯仍然没能利用这种看起来非常有前景的氛围。当时人们对内部敌人感到非常焦虑。而他的三K党，你知道，最多也就几百名成员，在佐治亚州可能不到100名核心成员，阿拉巴马州可能还有几个。绝望之中，他去找了一些公关人员。这是一对夫妇，名叫爱德华·杨·克拉克和伊丽莎白·泰勒，
and they ran a firm called the Southern Publicity Association. So just on these two characters, Edward Young Clark came from Atlanta, his father had been a Confederate Colonel. He worked in newspapers for a while, and then he went into PR. And Clark is unusually in this story, he's quite a well-educated man. He wears kind of glasses. He looks like a kind of newspaperman from a generic 1920s newspaper man. He's a little bit flashy, he's a little bit of a dilettante. So there's Clark. And then there's Mrs. Tyler, who is his partner. They had met bizarrely at a eugenics event in Atlanta. And Mrs. Tyler is a real character.
他们经营着一家名为“南方宣传协会”的公司。单说这两个人，爱德华·杨·克拉克来自亚特兰大，他的父亲曾是一名南方邦联上校。他曾在报社工作过一段时间，后来转行做了公关。克拉克在这个故事中很不寻常，他是一个受过良好教育的人。他戴着眼镜，看起来就像那种典型的1920年代的报人。他有点浮夸，也有点业余爱好者的气质。这就是克拉克。然后是他的合伙人泰勒夫人。奇怪的是，他们是在亚特兰大的一次优生学活动上认识的。泰勒夫人是个很有个性的人。
She came from a very poor family. She got married at 15. She's had a first child at 16. She'd been widowed. She'd had several more marriages and divorces. She's universally described as a large and forceful woman who always dresses in black. Like a sort of a sturdy southern version of Queen Victoria. That's exactly it.
她出身贫寒，15岁结婚，16岁生下第一个孩子。她后来守了寡，又经历了几次婚姻和离婚。人们普遍形容她是一位身材高大、性格强势的女性，总是穿着黑色的衣服。就像维多利亚女王那种结实的南方版本。确实如此。
She's very smart, by the way. I mean, they're very good at this PR business. They became a team, both in the boardroom and the bedroom, and they specialized in slightly dodgy political campaigns that were very fashionable in the 1910s. So if you're running a eugenics campaign, Clark and Mrs. Tyler are the people who will sell your campaign for you. Do you want to run an anti-immigration campaign? Get them on board. Do you want to promote the anti-saloon league?
顺便说一句，她非常聪明。我的意思是，他们在公关业务上非常在行。他们不仅在职场上是搭档，在生活中也是伴侣。他们专门从事那些在1910年代非常流行的、稍微有点不正当的政治运动。所以，如果你要开展一场优生学运动，克拉克和泰勒夫人就是能帮你推销的人。你想开展反移民运动吗？找他们准没错。你想推广“反酒馆联盟”吗？
they're your people. This is how Simmons met them. So they're coming from a particular political standpoint, which is clearly is something that they hold to be true if they were meeting into eugenics conference. Though eugenics is very popular in the 1910s in America. Very popular. They're at a political place which seems a bit odd to us now
找他们就对了。这就是西蒙斯遇见他们的方式。所以他们有着特定的政治立场，如果他们在优生学会议上相遇，这显然是他们所信奉的东西。尽管优生学在1910年代的美国非常流行。非常流行。他们所处的政治位置在我们现在看来有点奇怪，
and a bit kind of cranky and a bit on the fringe. And I suppose there was a slightly fringe element. to it. It's the place where enthusiasts go, you know, people who you find up yourself talking to them in the pub and their eyes slightly glaze over and then an hour passes and they've been talking constantly about their pet enthusiasm. So in 1920, they struck a deal with Simmons to promote the clan. And it's a very good deal for them. They will take full control of publicity and marketing and stuff. And in return, out of every dollar, they and their, they and their, they and their recruitment team will take home 80 cents. Wow, that is a good deal. He'll get 20 and they'll
有点古怪，也有点边缘化。我想确实存在一点边缘色彩。那是狂热分子聚集的地方，你知道，就是那种你在酒吧里和他们聊天，聊着聊着他们的眼神就开始发直，一个小时过去了，他们还在不停地谈论他们痴迷的东西。所以1920年，他们与西蒙斯达成协议，推广三K党。这对他们来说是一笔非常划算的交易。他们将完全控制宣传和营销等事务。作为回报，每收到一美元，他们和他们的招募团队就能拿走80美分。哇，这真是笔好买卖。他拿20美分，他们拿
get 80. And Simmons says, well, if you can really bring in new people, then fine, because he's not bringing in any new people. So he's laughing if they can really make it work. And actually, he is laughing because they are brilliant at it. And they approach the clan as a sales and marketing operation. The clan is a business, Simmons is the owner, he's hired them, they have only one job, and that is to get new customers, and they have Brinens at it. And the historian Linda Gordon, as she puts it, what they design is an aggressive state-of-the-art sales operation. So here's how it works. They divide the United States into nine regions, and they call them domains. So mad names is absolutely part of the marketing. It's part of the marketing. That's why they don't believe in their names.
80美分。西蒙斯说，好吧，如果你们真的能拉到新人，那就没问题，因为他自己一个新人也拉不到。所以如果他们真的能成功，他也会乐见其成。事实上，他确实乐开了花，因为他们在这方面简直是天才。他们把三K党当作一个销售和营销业务来运作。三K党是一家公司，西蒙斯是老板，他雇佣了他们，他们的唯一工作就是获取新客户，而且他们做得非常出色。正如历史学家琳达·戈登所言，他们设计的是一种激进的、最先进的销售运作模式。运作方式如下：他们将美国划分为九个区域，称之为“领域”。所以这些疯狂的名字绝对是营销的一部分。这是营销的一部分。这就是为什么他们不相信自己的名字。
They're doing it purely as a marketing exercise. There are nine domains. And each one is headed by a regional manager who is called the Grand Goblin. Of course he is. And each domain consists of obviously several normal states, but they're called the realms. And each realm has its own sub-manager. I hope it's just going to be a test at the end. Each realm has its own sub-manager who is called the King Cleggle. And he has a set of local salesmen who are called the Cleegals.
他们纯粹是把它当作一种营销手段。共有九个领域。每个领域由一名区域经理负责，被称为“大妖精”（Grand Goblin）。当然是这样。每个领域显然由几个正常的州组成，但它们被称为“王国”。每个王国都有自己的副经理。我希望最后不会有考试。每个王国都有自己的副经理，被称为“国王克莱格尔”（King Kleggle）。他手下有一组当地的推销员，被称为“克莱格尔”（Cleegals）。
Oh. It's like something from the Wizard of Oz. And Clark from the PR team, he runs the wholesale operation. He is the Imperial Cleggle, and he reports to Simmons, the owner, who is called the Imperial Wizard. So it really is like the Wizard of Oz. Do you think the Wizard of Oz was making play with all this? I don't know, actually. I hadn't thought of that.
哦。这就像《绿野仙踪》里的东西。公关团队的克拉克负责批发业务。他是“帝国克莱格尔”（Imperial Cleggle），他向老板西蒙斯汇报，西蒙斯被称为“帝国巫师”（Imperial Wizard）。所以这真的就像《绿野仙踪》。你认为《绿野仙踪》是在影射这些吗？我不知道，其实我没想过这个问题。
Maybe I'd have to look into it. So the Cleegals are basically salesmen. Their job, they're recruiters. And Clark and Tyler recruit them from other fraternal groups. Specifically, the masons. But how do they know the masons? Because they are in that world. And Simmons is in that world.
也许我得研究一下。所以“克莱格尔”基本上就是推销员。他们的工作是招募人员。克拉克和泰勒从其他兄弟会组织中招募他们。具体来说，是共济会。但他们怎么认识共济会成员的呢？因为他们就在那个圈子里。西蒙斯也在那个圈子里。
They know loads of people who are masons. Is he a Mason? Yes. Simmons is a Mason. Yes. Right. Okay. So they go to see, they go to Masons.
他们认识很多共济会成员。他是共济会成员吗？是的。西蒙斯是共济会成员。是的。好吧。所以他们去找共济会成员。
And they basically have a little quiet word with some maces. They say, hey, we'd like to make a little bit of money. This is an organization very like the Masons. If you recruit people, you will keep a lot of the money because you will. So, Tom, imagine you wanted to join the Ku Klux Klam. You would have, imagine I was recruiting you. you would have to pay me a $10 fee, and that would be called a kleck token. A clect token.
他们基本上会和一些共济会成员私下谈谈。他们说，嘿，我们想赚点小钱。这是一个非常像共济会的组织。如果你招募人员，你就能留下一大部分钱，因为你确实会。所以，汤姆，想象一下你想加入三K党。你得付给我10美元的费用，这被称为“克莱克代币”（kleck token）。一个克莱克代币。
Right. So you would pay me your clec token. And of your clect token, I would keep $4 out of the 10. I would give $1 to the King Cleggle. And I would give 50 cents to the Grand Goblin. Right. And of the rest of the money, William Simmons, the owner, gets $2. and Clark and Mrs. Tyler get $2.50.
对。所以你会付给我你的克莱克代币。在你的克莱克代币中，我会留下4美元，给“国王克莱格尔”1美元，给“大妖精”50美分。对。剩下的钱里，老板威廉·西蒙斯拿2美元，克拉克和泰勒夫人拿2.50美元。
So basically, you have just joined, and we have all profited enormously. A pyramid scheme. It's a pyramid scheme. Yeah. Because the bosses, the people at the top make the most money. But every member is allowed to recruit other members. So there's an incentive. So once you've joined, you could go to James Holland.
所以基本上，你刚加入，我们就都赚翻了。一个传销计划。这是一个传销计划。是的。因为老板们，处于顶层的人赚得最多。但每个成员都被允许招募其他成员。所以这是一种激励。所以一旦你加入了，你就可以去找詹姆斯·霍兰德。
And you could recruit him and get to recruit his friends, and you would keep 40% of his KLEC token. I'd be a winner. You would be a winner. You'd be an important person in the community, and you'd be doing your bit for the United States of America. And I'd have a great title. You would.
你可以招募他，并招募他的朋友，你就可以保留他克莱克代币的40%。我会成为赢家。你会成为赢家。你会成为社区里的重要人物，而且你是在为美利坚合众国尽一份力。而且我会有个很棒的头衔。你会有的。
You'd rise to be the Grand Goblin. So now you've paid your collect token. What happens to you? This is what happens. I would invite you to the lodge, to the Clavern. You would kneel in prayer before a burning cross. So they've devised this mad ritual. They've made this up because they think it's fun.
你会升到“大妖精”。现在你已经付了你的克莱克代币。你身上会发生什么？这就是会发生的事。我会邀请你去会所，去“克莱文”（Clavern）。你会跪在燃烧的十字架前祈祷。所以他们设计了这个疯狂的仪式。他们编造了这个仪式，因为他们觉得这很有趣。
And this is Mrs. Tyler and... Yeah, with... Simmons, basically. And Simmons. You would kneel in a circle of other clansmen who'd all be in their white robes. You would swear an oath of allegiance. You'd promise to uphold the flag in the Constitution. You would promise to defend free public schools.
这是泰勒夫人和……是的，和……西蒙斯，基本上。还有西蒙斯。你会跪在其他穿着白袍的三K党成员中间。你会宣誓效忠。你会承诺维护国旗和宪法。你会承诺捍卫免费公立学校。
We'll explain why later on. You'd defend free speech, separation of church estate, individual liberty, and inevitably white supremacy. And what is what is white supremac is called white supremacy? Yes. You read that out right at the beginning. The phrase white supremacy. Of course, yes.
我们稍后会解释原因。你会捍卫言论自由、政教分离、个人自由，以及不可避免的白人至上主义。什么是白人至上主义？是的。你一开始就读出来了。白人至上主义这个词。当然，是的。
But as we will see, white supremacy has a very particular meaning. It's not just about skin color. It's also about religion. You would be given your outfit. This is a special, there's the white robe within the insignia, which is a kind of Prussian cross. There is a sash. There is the helmet with the cone. And there's also a red tassel.
但正如我们将看到的，白人至上主义有着非常特殊的含义。它不仅仅关乎肤色。它也关乎宗教。你会得到你的装备。这是一个特殊的装备，有带有徽章的白袍，徽章是一种普鲁士十字。有一条腰带。有一个带尖顶的头盔。还有一个红色的流苏。
Oh, like the Inca. Like the Inca, yeah. That surprised me. And then there's a sort of mask, which is the kind of cloth that hangs down over your face. Now, you might say, could I make my own costume like the original clan did? Oh no. Oh no. Not at all. And Dominic, as part of the costume, a garter by any chance. Yes. It's a sash. Maybe you can repurpose garters as sashes. So the costume costs Clark and Mrs. Tyler $2 to manufacture, but they charge you $6 as further $6.50. That is the American dream. So now you've joined and you are a member of the Clavern and you're
哦，像印加人一样。像印加人，是的。这让我很惊讶。然后还有一种面具，就是那种垂在你脸上的布。现在，你可能会说，我能像最初的三K党那样自己做服装吗？哦，不。哦，不。绝对不行。多米尼克，服装的一部分里有吊袜带吗？是的。那是一条腰带。也许你可以把吊袜带改造成腰带。所以这套服装克拉克和泰勒夫人的制造成本是2美元，但他们向你收取6美元，甚至6.50美元。这就是美国梦。所以现在你加入了，你是“克莱文”的一员，你处于
You're at the foot of the great ladder of Clancraft. And if you advance through the ranks, you can go from being a Klansman to a knight chamelea, to a knight of the great forest. Again, badly spelled two hours. That's Forrest with two hours because it's named after Nathan Bedford Forest. Oh, of course. Yeah, the General, the Confederate General who was the war criminal. Exactly.
“三K党工艺”巨大阶梯的最底层。如果你在等级中晋升，你可以从三K党成员变成“变色龙骑士”，再到“大森林骑士”。同样，拼写很糟糕，有两个R。那是Forrest，有两个R，因为它是以内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特命名的。哦，当然。是的，那位将军，那位南方邦联将军，那个战争罪犯。没错。
War criminal. And then you can rise to become a knight of the Midnight Mystery. Who wouldn't want that? The head of the Clavern is the exalted Cyclops. and above him are the officers of the invisible empire. And these are, there's the imperial wizard at the top. And then below him are the three great claliffs. And then there's the great clabby.
战争罪犯。然后你可以升为“午夜神秘骑士”。谁不想那样呢？“克莱文”的负责人是“崇高的独眼巨人”（exalted Cyclops）。在他之上是“隐形帝国”的官员。这就是，顶端是帝国巫师。在他下面是三位伟大的“克拉利夫”（claliffs）。然后是伟大的“克拉比”（clabby）。
There's the great grab. There's the great clod. And the great knight hawk. They are having a laugh. And every week, your clavon will have a clonclay. A cloncliffe. I mean, honestly. And every month, you know, if you keep going, every month, you'll be able to go to the clonverse.
还有伟大的“格拉布”（grab）。还有伟大的“克洛德”（clod）。以及伟大的“夜鹰”（knight hawk）。他们简直是在开玩笑。每周，你的“克莱文”都会举行一次“克隆克莱”（clonclay）。一个“克隆克利夫”（cloncliffe）。说真的。每个月，你知道，如果你坚持下去，每个月你都能参加“克隆弗斯”（clonverse）。
And when you want to initiate a new member, you will have a converse. No, clonvocation. No, no, no, no. No. If you have given yourself away there, you don't know the difference in a conversation and a clonvocation. No, I don't. That's because I'm an undercover agent. You've outed yourself there.
当你想要启动一名新成员时，你会举行一次“克隆弗斯”。不，是“克隆沃凯申”（clonvocation）。不，不，不，不。不。你在这里露馅了，你不知道“对话”（conversation）和“克隆沃凯申”（clonvocation）的区别。不，我不知道。那是因为我是卧底特工。你在这里暴露了自己。
You're almost certainly a Catholic. What's going to happen to me now? Because a conversation is when you initiate a new member. But the National Convention is the clonvocation. Now, what do you actually do when you have a conclave? Basically, you just sit around reciting this mad babble. And then you sing some Protestant hymns. And basically you spend a lot of time networking.
你几乎肯定是个天主教徒。我现在会怎么样？因为“对话”是当你启动一名新成员时。但全国大会是“克隆沃凯申”。现在，当你举行“克隆克莱”时，你实际上在做什么？基本上，你只是坐在那里背诵这些疯狂的胡言乱语。然后你唱一些新教赞美诗。基本上你花很多时间进行社交。
That's what you spend most of your time doing. Here is the regional sales manager for this. Here is the local sheriff. Here is so-and-so who's a very leading attorney in Des Moines, Iowa, or whatever. So like the masons. Yes, exactly. There's no doubt whatsoever. It gave people a genuine sense of community. So David Chalmers in his book, Hooded Americanism, says, you know, you're living in some two-bit place in the middle of nowhere, and you are, you know, the deputy sales organizer or whatever.
这就是你大部分时间在做的事情。这是区域销售经理。这是当地警长。这是某某人，他是得梅因的一位非常著名的律师，等等。就像共济会一样。是的，完全正确。毫无疑问。它给了人们一种真正的社区感。所以大卫·查尔默斯在他的书《戴兜帽的美国主义》中说，你知道，你住在某个偏僻地方的二流小镇，你是副销售组织者之类的。
And this gives you a chance to live out this incredibly rich and exciting in her life. You know, you might one day get to meet the great clod. That's really exciting. And it's brilliant. Now, that said, there is a dark side to the clan. And we've, for all the sort of laughing at the great clallif or whatever, there is definitely a dark side. And this is what we'll come to. Because what Clark and Mrs. Tyler realized, they're very good PR people and salespeople,
这给了你一个机会去过这种极其丰富和令人兴奋的内心生活。你知道，你可能有一天能见到伟大的“克洛德”。那真的很令人兴奋。这太棒了。话虽如此，三K党确实有黑暗的一面。尽管我们嘲笑伟大的“克拉利夫”之类的，但它绝对有黑暗的一面。这就是我们要谈到的。因为克拉克和泰勒夫人意识到，他们是非常优秀的公关人员和销售人员，
but they realize that basically the way to attract people is to find out what and whom they really hate. Oh, it's kind of Elon Musk like. Right. Because America in the early 20s is a very anxious place. very heady sense of social and cultural change, political change as well, and a lot of people don't like it. And so Clark and Tyler draw the line very starkly. They say on the one side, there are decent men and women of the clan who are standing up for 100% Americanism. And on
但他们意识到，吸引人们的基本方法是找出他们真正讨厌什么和讨厌谁。哦，这有点像埃隆·马斯克。对。因为20年代初的美国是一个非常焦虑的地方。有一种非常强烈的社会和文化变革感，政治变革也是如此，很多人不喜欢它。所以克拉克和泰勒划清了界限。他们说，一方面，有三K党体面的男人和女人，他们为100%的美国主义挺身而出。而在
the other, there is a group of sinister subversives who are plotting to undermine everything America stands for. And Dominic, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we will find out who those subversives are and how far the clan. is prepared to go to destroy them. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society, and it's Tabby and Dominic here from the book club, Gollhanger's latest show. Now, Tabby, as you know,
另一方面，有一群邪恶的颠覆分子，他们密谋破坏美国所代表的一切。多米尼克，我们休息一下好吗？回来后，我们将找出那些颠覆分子是谁，以及三K党准备走多远去摧毁他们。本集由Folio Society赞助，我是塔比和多米尼克，来自Gollhanger最新节目《读书俱乐部》。现在，塔比，如你所知，
there are some books that you read once, but there are others you especially return to again and again. And those second kind of books, they really deserve to last, don't they? That's what the Folio Society does. They are an independent, employee-owned publisher based in London. Every book is produced with specially commissioned beautiful artwork and a specially commissioned introduction
有些书你读一次就够了，但有些书你特别会反复阅读。后一种书，它们确实值得流传，不是吗？这就是Folio Society所做的。他们是一家位于伦敦的独立、员工持股的出版商。每一本书都配有特别委托的精美插图和特别委托的序言，
that puts the story in its context. Folio Society publishes the books we love from Bronte to Dickens, from Margaret Atwood to Tom Holland. The books can feel like works of art in their own right. They're built around the text, the stories that last in books that are made to last. If a story matters, keep it properly. Find it at foliosociety.com slash the book club. That's foliosociety.com slash the book club.
将故事置于其背景中。Folio Society出版我们喜爱的书籍，从勃朗特到狄更斯，从玛格丽特·阿特伍德到汤姆·霍兰德。这些书本身就像艺术品一样。它们围绕文本构建，那些经久不衰的故事，那些旨在经久不衰的书籍。如果一个故事很重要，就好好保存它。在foliosociety.com/thebookclub找到它们。那是foliosociety.com/thebookclub。
At Desjardin, our business is helping yours. We're here to support your business through every stage of growth, from your first pitch to your first acquisition. Whether it's improving cash flow or exploring investment banking solutions, with Desjardin business, it's all under one roof. So join the more than 400,000 Canadian entrepreneurs who already count on us. And contact Desjardin today. We'd love to talk. Business. One plus one equals more of the greatest stories. Hulu on Disney Plus.
在Desjardin，我们的业务是帮助您的业务。我们在这里支持您的业务度过每一个成长阶段，从您的第一次推介到您的第一次收购。无论是改善现金流还是探索投资银行解决方案，在Desjardin商业，一切都在一个屋檐下。所以加入已经依赖我们的40多万加拿大企业家吧。今天就联系Desjardin。我们很乐意交谈。商业。一加一等于更多伟大的故事。Hulu在Disney Plus上。
Stories about survivors. The most dangerous planet. Family. Retribution. Murder. Prophecy. Beer and propane. Bobby Miller.
关于幸存者的故事。最危险的星球。家庭。报应。谋杀。预言。啤酒和丙烷。鲍比·米勒。
Blake panting, ultimate soldier. Chicago, all right? The best of the best stories now with even more from Hulu. Amazing. Have it all with 3-1 Disney Plus. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to the rest of history. So before the break, we promised you that all this networking and barbecuing and great cludding and stuff would be taking a dark turn.
布莱克喘着气，终极士兵。芝加哥，好吗？最好的故事现在有了更多来自Hulu的内容。太棒了。通过3-1 Disney Plus拥有这一切。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。所以在休息之前，我们向你们保证，所有这些社交、烧烤和伟大的“克洛德”之类的活动都会转向黑暗。
So Dominic, what is this dark turn and where does it take us? So let me just set the context for the dark term. The second clan was relaunched in about 1920, and it was a staggering success. So by about 1921, it is attracting 100,000 members a week and turning over $25 million a year. Now, some historians question those figures. They say actually the clan, they're pretty, their accounts are a mess. A lot of people probably aren't paying their dues. But even so, the growth is extraordinary.
多米尼克，这种黑暗转向是什么，它把我们带向何方？让我来设定一下黑暗转向的背景。第二个三K党在1920年左右重新启动，并取得了惊人的成功。到1921年左右，它每周吸引10万名成员，年营业额达2500万美元。现在，一些历史学家对这些数字表示怀疑。他们说实际上三K党的账目一团糟。很多人可能根本没有缴纳会费。但即便如此，增长也是非同寻常的。
And actually, once we start to talk about what kind of people join, then we'll be able to see who the enemy. is our. So the people who join, initially they're people who are already members of other fraternal organisations. So the masons, first of all, a Klegel arrives in a new town and he would approach the masons first and get their membership lists. How does you do that? I thought the masons kept their membership lists top secret. Because he goes to the lodge, he shakes people's hands. So they become a Mason themselves? And then they... Yeah, they're often the masons themselves. The Klegals are often recruited from the masons. Right. Would you like to make a bit of extra money? That's how it is.
事实上，一旦我们开始谈论加入的是什么样的人，我们就能看出敌人是谁。所以加入的人，最初是那些已经是其他兄弟会组织成员的人。首先是共济会，一个“克莱格尔”到达一个新城镇，他会首先接触共济会并获取他们的会员名单。他怎么做到的？我以为共济会把他们的会员名单列为绝密。因为他去会所，他与人握手。所以他们自己也成了共济会成员？然后他们……是的，他们通常就是共济会成员。“克莱格尔”通常是从共济会中招募的。对。你想多赚点钱吗？就是这样。
they will often hold the first clan meetings in Masonic halls or in Oddfellow's halls or Woodman's halls. And in some places, as many as three out of four members of the clan were already Mason's. So it's like you go to the masons on Tuesday. Would you like to go to another thing on Thursday? Yeah, why not? And you get a special costume. You can have the privilege of paying $6.50 for the special costume. Also, if you recruit some other people, you can make a bit of money.
他们经常在共济会大厅、奇人会大厅或伐木工人大厅举行第一次三K党会议。在某些地方，多达四分之三的三K党成员已经是共济会成员了。所以就像你周二去共济会。你想周四去参加另一个活动吗？是的，为什么不呢？而且你还能得到一套特殊的服装。你可以有幸花6.50美元买这套特殊的服装。此外，如果你招募其他人，你还能赚点钱。
I mean, it's a reminder of how boring life must have been. in the 1920s. I guess so. If this is your idea of fun. Yeah. Talking about people who are boring, and I hope this doesn't defend some of our listeners. The second largest clan constituencies
我的意思是，这提醒了我们1920年代的生活一定有多么无聊。我想是吧。如果这是你认为的乐趣的话。是的。谈到那些无聊的人，我希望这不会冒犯我们的一些听众。第二个最大的三K党选区
among Methodist ministers. So there were some esturess that 40,000 Methodist ministers became clan members. And some of them rose to be as high as exalted cyclopses or grand dragons. And what do you think the appeal is for them? The clan is echoing everything
是在卫理公会牧师中。据估计有4万名卫理公会牧师成为了三K党成员。其中一些人升到了“崇高的独眼巨人”或“大龙”的高位。你认为对他们来说吸引力是什么？三K党呼应了卫理公会牧师所说和所相信的一切，关于饮酒、关于天主教、关于美国、关于清廉的生活，所有这些东西。三K党基本上，克拉克和泰勒夫人，调整了三K党的信息，使其完全模仿卫理公会牧师在政治和社会上对他们的会众所说的话。运作方式是这样的：当三K党到达一个城镇时，他们会接触当地的牧师，当地的卫理公会牧师，他们会对他说是，你想终身免费加入三K党这个新组织吗？
that a Methodist minister says and believes in about drink, about Catholicism, about America, about clean living, all of this kind of stuff. The clan basically, Clark and Mrs. Tyler, adapt the clan's message so that it exactly mimics what Methodist ministers are telling their congregations politically and socially. So the way it will work is this. When the clan arrive in a town, they will approach the local minister, the local Methodist minister, and they will say to him, would you like free membership of the clan for life, this new group?
而且，如果他们认为他是一个特别有前途的客户，他们会给他“克洛德”的头衔。谁不会为此而心动呢？是的，我知道。疯了。而“克洛德”是“克莱文”的当地牧师。当然。然后一旦他们这样做了，
And also, if they think he's a particularly promising customer, they will offer him the title of a clod. Who wouldn't leap at that? Yeah, I know. Bonkers. And a clod is the local chaplain of the Clavern. Of course. And then once they've done that,
在周六晚上，他们会在镇上的主街上举行游行，最好是骑马或开福特T型车。所以骑马非常令人兴奋。福特T型车以另一种方式令人兴奋，因为它太现代了。他们会在镇外点燃一个十字架，最好是在山坡上，非常壮观。然后通过与这位卫理公会牧师的安排，在周日的礼拜上，这可能会
on Saturday nights, they would hold a parade down Main Street in a town, ideally on horseback or in a Model T car. So horseback is very exciting. Model T car is very exciting in a different way because it's so modern. and they will light a cross outside the town, ideally on a hillside, a great spectacle. Then by arrangement with this Methodist minister, on Sunday at the service, which is probably
非常拥挤，因为正如你所说，1920年代没什么别的事可做，他们会穿着长袍在礼拜中途静静地走进教堂，然后他们会向牧师捐赠30或40美元给教堂。然后牧师会向他的会众说，这一切都是预先安排好的，他说，上帝，这些人真是太棒了。这是一个多么出色的组织，给教堂捐钱。我想我们都应该加入。
going to be very busy, because as you rightly say, there's nothing else to do in the 1920s, they will march silently into church halfway through the service in their robes, and then they will present the minister with a donation of $30 or $40 towards the church. And the minister will then say to his congregation, this is all prearranged, he'll say, God, these are absolutely fantastic people. What a brilliant organisation this is to give the money to the church. I think we should all join.
然后每个人，包括三K党成员，都唱《前进，基督精兵》，每个人都玩得很开心，镇民们想，上帝，这太棒了，这些家伙穿着白袍出现了，他们给了教堂这么多钱。这太棒了。
And then everybody, including the Klansmen, sing, onward Christian soldiers, and everyone's had a great time, and the townsfolk think, God, this is brilliant, these blokes have turned up with white robes, they've given all this money to the church. This is fantastic.
这有什么黑暗的一面吗？确实有，我们马上就会谈到。但就加入的人而言，一些听众可能会想，好吧，这吸引的是白痴，这吸引的是那些感到被抛弃的人。这吸引的是被变革所困的人。并非如此。
Is there in any way a dark side? There is exactly, and we'll come to that in just a second. But just on the people who join, some listeners may be thinking, well, this appeals to idiots, This appeals to people who feel left behind. This appeals to people stranded by change. Not so.
对此做了大量研究的历史学家表明，加入的人往往是受人尊敬的中产阶级。他们是医生、会计师、牙医、艺术家、兽医、外科医生，他们是所有这些类型的人。他们都加入了，这些人有两个共同点。他们是白人，他们是新教徒。
The historians who've done loads of work on this have shown that the people who join tend to be respectable middle class people. They are doctors, their accountants, they're dentists, their artists, their vets, their surgeons, they're all these kinds of things. And they all join, and these people have two things in common. They are white and they are Protestants.
这就引出了黑暗面的问题。三K党非常擅长利用1920年代新教徒的文化焦虑，那些让他们烦恼的事情。舞厅、好莱坞、不得体的服装、女性的性行为，这些东西。最重要的是，饮酒和禁酒令，我们稍后会谈到。演讲者和三K党报纸最强调一个信息。美国正面临生存危机，我们正被内部敌人破坏。特别是，白人新教徒美国正被吞没。盎格鲁-撒克逊新教徒、黄蜂（WASP）和其他人之间将发生种族战争。
And this brings us to the issue of the dark side. The clan are brilliant at tapping the cultural anxieties of Protestants in the 1920s, the things that annoy them. Dance halls, Hollywood, immodest clothing, women's sexual behaviour, these kinds of things. And above all, drink and prohibition, which will come to. And the speakers and then clan newspapers hammer home one message above all. America is facing an existential crisis we're being undermined by enemies within. In particular, white Protestant America is being engulfed. There's going to be a race war between Anglo-Saxon Protestants, between wasps and the rest.
这在1920年代初非常普遍。所以任何读过《了不起的盖茨比》的人，里面有一个叫汤姆·布坎南的角色。在书的前面，他正在读一个叫洛斯罗普·斯托达德的人写的书，一本真实的书，叫《崛起的有色人种浪潮对抗白人世界至上》。汤姆·布坎南在《了不起的盖茨比》中说，作为统治种族的我们，必须小心，否则这些其他种族将控制一切。这非常像傅满洲，不是吗？非常像傅满洲。
And this is very common in the early 1920s. So anybody who's read The Great Gatsby, there's a character in that called Tom Buchanan. And at a point earlier in the book, he's reading this book by a guy called Lothrop Studdard, a real book called The Rising Tide of Color against white world supremacy. and Tom Buchanan says in the Great Gatsby, it's up to us who are the dominant race to watch out or these other races will have control of things. It's very fu-manchu, isn't it, as well? Very fu-manchu.
是的，完全是那样。黄祸。你知道，这完全是20世纪初那种焦虑，即白人盎格鲁-撒克逊血统将被所有这些其他种族所淹没。因此，在这种背景下，三K党中的许多人充满了恐惧、怨恨、对其他种族的仇恨。这绝对是事实。他们的信条，你一开始读的，
Yeah, exactly that. Yellow peril. You know, it's completely of that early 20th century anxiety that the white Anglo-Saxon stock will be overwhelmed by all of these other races. So against that background, a lot of people in the clan are full of fear, resentment, hatred of other races. That's definitely the case. Their creed, you read out at the beginning,
三K党信条的一个版本，正如他们所称的那样。我们相信白人种族的至高无上。我们的弟弟们被教导尊重造物主以其卓越智慧所划定的出生和肤色的界限，这是公正和正确的。这里所说的是非裔美国人。此时南方的黑人因为吉姆·克劳法、种族隔离等原因再次被降为从属地位，而三K党就是为了维护这一点。但这里有一件事可能会让一些听众感到惊讶。反黑人仇恨只是第二个三K党的一个小主题。20年代对美国黑人有可怕的暴行。最著名的是1921年的塔尔萨大屠杀，当时数百人在塔尔萨被杀，
one version of the clan's creed, as they call it. We believe in the supremacy of the white race. And it's just and right that our younger brothers should be taught to respect those lines of birth and color which the creator in his superior wisdom has drawn. What it's talking about there is African Americans. Black people at this point in the South have been reduced to subordinate status again because of the Jim Crow laws, segregation or not, and the clan is all about preserving that. But here's the thing that may surprise some listeners. Anti-black hatred is only a minor theme of the second clam. There are terrible outrages against black Americans in the 20s. The most famous is the Tulsa massacre in 1921, when hundreds of people were killed in Tulsa,
俄克拉荷马州。那是他们被飞机袭击的地方吗？是的，完全正确，完全是那样。塔尔萨有一个非常成功的中产阶级黑人社区，他们的白人邻居基本上转而攻击他们并轰炸了他们，据称。他们是否真的轰炸了他们，我的意思是，一些历史学家仍然在争论这一点，但他们可能确实这样做了，这么说吧。无论如何，三K党没有参与其中。原因在于三K党在黑人人口非常少的州最受欢迎。它真正的目标是另外两个群体。引用未来的帝国巫师海勒姆·埃文斯的话，我们下次会谈到他，“黑人对美国主义的威胁不像犹太人或罗马天主教徒那样。”
Oklahoma. Is that where the planes, where they got attacked by planes? Yes, exactly, exactly that. Tulsa had a very successful black middle class and their white neighbours basically turned on them and bombed them, supposedly. Whether they did bomb them, I mean, that's some historians still argue about that, but they might have done, put it that way. Anyway, the clan was not involved in this. And the reason for that is that the clan is most popular in states that have very small black populations. It's real targets at two other groups. And to quote the future imperial wizard, Hiram Evans, who will be talking about next time, The Negro is not the menace to Americanism in the same sense that the Jew or the Roman Catholic is a menace.
所以这些才是真正的目标，犹太人和天主教徒。首先是犹太人，1920年美国大约有350万犹太人，他们主要在东北部的城市。这绝对是反犹太主义的繁荣时期。汽车大亨亨利·福特资助了《锡安长老会纪要》的发行。所以亨利·福特非常反犹太。三K党报纸也非常反犹太。他们会谈论华尔街的犹太阴谋，诱拐白人女孩的犹太阴谋。他们谈论好莱坞是一种肮脏的犹太暗示的毒流。然而，如果你住在印第安纳州或俄亥俄州或其他地方，你可能根本不认识任何犹太人。你知道，现在的犹太人口非常少。因此，犹太人并不是一个非常可信的威胁或一个非常令人满意的目标。你知道，仇恨的程度其实很低。真的很低。但天主教徒是另一回事。20年代初美国有超过1800万天主教徒。而且他们比美国犹太人明显更有影响力。他们有天主教国会议员。他们有天主教市长。纽约州州长阿尔·史密斯就是天主教徒。反天主教在美利坚政治文化中根深蒂固。它显然可以追溯到美国殖民地的建立，追溯到17世纪。19世纪有各种各样的本土主义团体和骚乱。所以三K党有很多可以利用的东西。有一个他们可以利用的深厚传统。再次引用未来的帝国巫师海勒姆·埃文斯的话，“罗马教会从其领导层、政治、思想和成员来看，实际上和积极地是异类的、非美国的和反美国的。”而且有很多人对此并不感到意外，
So these are the real targets, Jews and Catholics. Jews first, there are maybe three and a half million Jews in America in 1920, and they're mainly in the cities of the northeast. And this is definitely a boom period for anti-Semitism. Henry Ford of Car fame has funded the distribution of the protocols of the elders of Zion. So Henry Ford is very anti-Semitic. And Klan newspapers are very anti-Semitic. They will talk about Jewish conspiracies on Wall Street, Jewish conspiracies to abduct white girls. They talk about Hollywood being a kind of a poisonous flood of filthy Jewish suggestion. However, if you live in Indiana or Ohio or wherever, you probably don't know any Jews. You know, the Jewish population now is very small. And as a result, Jews are not a terribly plausible threat or a very satisfying target. You know, the level of hate. hatred is quite low, really. It's quite low level. But Catholics are a different proposition. There are more than 18 million Catholics in America in the early 20s. And they're much more
这就是他们从小被教导要相信的。你知道，他们认为这是成为美国人的一部分。三K党是否担心他们打扮得像圣周期间的西班牙忏悔者？不，一点也不。他们穿着他们与第一个三K党联系在一起的服装，因为他们在电影中看到了它们。基本上就是这样，在《一个国家的诞生》中。所以你在三K党报纸中最常见的主题是教皇正在领导一场针对美国的阴谋。三K党的《火十字》杂志会称他为“塔伊巴的戴戈牧师”。他们声称他正在组织大规模移民来掠夺、抢劫、强奸和谋杀新教徒美国人。
obviously influential than Jewish Americans are. They're a Catholic congressman. They're Catholic mayors. The governor of New York, Al Smith is a Catholic. And anti-Catholicism is very deeply rooted in American political culture. It goes back to the foundation of the American colonies, obviously, to the 17th century. There had been all kinds of nativist groups and riots in the 19th century. So there's loads for the clan to play with. There's a deep tradition that they can tap. And to quote Hiram Evans, future imperial wizard again, the Roman church is fundamentally and irredeemably in its leadership and its politics and thought and in membership, actually and actively alien, un-American and anti-American. And there are a lot of people for whom this is not news,
我的意思是，这种修辞和新世界中的英国定居点一样古老。和英国定居点一样古老，在21世纪也非常可辨认，不是吗？有一群天主教徒正在渗入我们的边界，他们将要强奸、抢劫、偷窃，他们正在把他们最糟糕的人送给我们，所有这些事情。我的意思是，近年来我们听到了很多这样的说法。三K党还会声称，基本上每当一个儿子，这又是美国反天主教宣传中的一个古老主题，
this is what they've always been brought up to believe. You know, they see this as being part of being American. Is there any sense of anxiety in the clan that they're dressing up as Spanish penitents from Holy Week? No, not at all. They're wearing the costumes that they associate with the first clan because they've seen them in the film. That's basically it in the birth of a nation. So the most common theme you're getting clan newspapers is that the Pope is leading a conspiracy against the United States. The clan fiery cross magazine would call him the Dego priest on the Taiba. And they claimed that he was organizing mass immigration to plunder, pillage, rape and murder, Protestant Americans.
每当一个天主教家庭有一个儿子，按照传统，父亲必须向当地天主教教堂的武器储备库捐赠另一件武器，天主教徒有一天将用这些武器崛起并压倒新教当局。我的意思是，这感觉像是1640年代的东西，你不觉得吗？是的，绝对是。
I mean, this is rhetoric as old as old as the English settlements in the new world. As old as the English settlements and very recognizable in the 21st century, no? That there are a load of Catholics who are seeping through our borders, who are going to rape, pillage, steal, they're sending us their very worst people, all of that kind of thing. I mean, we have heard quite a lot of this in recent years. The clown would also claim that basically every time a son, this is again an old theme in anti-Catholic propaganda in America,
这绝对感觉像那样。他们声称天主教徒在去教堂时发誓，有一天他们将焚烧、浪费、煮沸、剥皮、勒死并活埋新教徒，并将他们孩子的头撞在墙上，剖开他们妇女的肚子，所有这些事情。三K党说这就是天主教徒所做的。这就是他们发的誓。同样，17世纪。非常像三十年战争之类的。完全正确。反天主教表现出来的两种实际方式。首先，是在学校问题上。所以，记得我们谈到当你宣誓加入三K党时，你必须宣誓维护免费公立学校。原因在于三K党不喜欢人们去天主教学校的想法。它希望他们成为100%的美国人。三K党认为每个人都应该去同一所学校，你知道，公立学校，没有针对
that every time a Catholic family has a son, sort of by tradition, the father has to donate another weapon to the local Catholic churches' stockpile of weapons with which the Catholics are going to rise up one day and overpower the Protestant authorities. I mean, this feels like something from the 1640s, wouldn't you say? Yeah, absolutely.
不同宗教的单独学校。他们认为要成为100%的美国人，你必须是新教徒吗？是的。哦，是的，毫无疑问。这适用于犹太人吗？是的。所以如果一个犹太人皈依并成为新教徒？我想是的。我想是这样。我的意思是，我不认为这是一个非常完善的世界观。他们不在“克隆沃凯申”中讨论这个问题。我认为关于犹太人有趣的是，有一些关于人们的故事，所以我认为是在某个地方，比如，我不知道。在一个小镇，有一个犹太家庭，他们总是被包括在三K党中。三K党太大了，他们有烧烤之类的活动，
This feels absolutely like that. they claim that the Catholics when they are you know when they go to church swear an oath that one day they will burn, waste, boil, flay, strangle and bury alive Protestants and dash their children's heads against the wall and rip open the stomachs of their women and all of this kind of thing. The clan says this is what Catholics do. This is the oath they swear. And again, so 17th century. Very 30 years war or something. Exactly. And the two practical ways in which this is, anti-Catholicism expresses itself. First of all, it's in the question of schools. So, remember we were talking about when you swore your oath to join the clan, you would have to swear to uphold free public schools. And the reason for that is that the clan does not like the idea of people going to Catholic schools. It wants them to become 100% American. And the clan thinks everybody should go to the same schools, you know, public schools, and no separate schools for
他们总是邀请那个犹太家庭参加，人们对他们非常友好，从不让他们感到不受欢迎，所有这些事情。我想有时其中一些是表演性的和修辞性的，但并不总是这样。我的意思是，我不想淡化三K党的暴力。无论如何，从这一点转向另一个大问题。
different religions. And do they think that to be 100% American, you have to be a Protestant? Yes. Oh, yeah, undoubtedly. And would this apply to Jews as well? Yes. So if a Jew converts and becomes a Protestant? I suspect yes. I think so. I mean, I don't think it's a terribly well-worked-out worldview. They don't discuss this in the convocation. I think the interesting thing about the Jews is there are stories about people so that I think it was somewhere like, I don't. where there was a small town and there was one Jewish family and they were always included in the clan. The clan was so big they had barbecues and stuff
另一个大问题是禁酒令。如果你把禁酒令从这个故事中拿走，三K党永远不会如此成功。所以禁酒令，同样，深深植根于美国的宗教历史，植根于新教。有像“基督教妇女节制联盟”或“反酒馆联盟”这样的团体，它们与三K党之间在主题和人员上有很大的交叉。所以像三K党这样的节制团体相信清理城市。他们不信任移民。他们痴迷于对美国家庭的威胁。
and they would always invite the Jewish family along and people were very friendly to them and never made them feel unwelcome and all of this kind of thing. I think sometimes some of this is a little bit performative and rhetorical, but not always. I mean, I don't want to underplay the violence of the clan. Anyway, to move on from that to the other big issue.
节制团体从相同的群体中招募人员，即卫理公会、浸信会、基督门徒会，这些类型的团体。在1920年代，禁酒令已成为法律。节制团体如愿以偿。1919年的第18修正案，然后是1920年强制执行的《沃尔斯泰德法案》。但这就是你给三K党礼物的地方。禁酒令的执行非常无力。基本上是因为根据《沃尔斯泰德法案》，联邦和地方当局应该共同努力
The other big issue is prohibition. If you took prohibition out of this story, the clan would never have been so successful. So prohibition, again, very deeply rooted in America's religious history, in Protestantism. There were groups like the Women's Christian Temperance Union or the Anti-Saloon League, and there's a lot of crossover between them and the clan, in themes and in personnel. So temperance groups like the clan believed in cleaning up the cities. They distrusted immigrants. They were obsessed with threats to the American family.
另一个大问题是禁酒令。如果把禁酒令从这个故事中剔除，三K党绝不会如此成功。因此，禁酒令同样深深植根于美国的宗教历史和新教之中。当时存在诸如基督教妇女禁酒联合会或反沙龙联盟之类的组织，它们与三K党在主题和人员构成上有许多重叠。因此，像三K党一样的禁酒团体相信要净化城市。他们不信任移民。他们痴迷于对美国家庭的威胁。
and temperance groups recruited from the same pools, which is Methodists, Baptists, Disciples of Christ, these kinds of groups. And in the 1920s, prohibition has become law. The temperance groups have got their way. The 18th Amendment in 1990 and then the Volstead Act in 1920 that enforces it. But here's where you get the gift to the clan. Enforcement of prohibition is very feeble. Basically because under the Volstead Act, the federal and local authorities are meant to work
而禁酒团体从相同的群体中招募成员，即卫理公会教徒、浸信会教徒、基督会教徒等这类群体。到了20世纪20年代，禁酒令已成为法律。禁酒团体得偿所愿。1919年的第18修正案，随后是1920年强制执行该修正案的沃尔斯泰德法案。但这就是三K党获得馈赠的地方。禁酒令的执行非常无力。基本上是因为根据沃尔斯泰德法案，联邦和地方当局本应协同工作
together to enforce it, but it's not spelled out exactly how they will do that. And the local authorities often aren't really interested in enforcing prohibition. They're not bothered about it. They don't think it'll work. So there's that element to it. And that annoys the clan because the clan are very pro-temperance. But also, it's well known that Catholics don't like prohibition. And that's not because Catholics particularly love drinking. It's because Catholics don't like the idea of the federal government regulating moral life. Obviously they don't. That's what they say. Well, I think they're obviously that if you're a Catholic, the idea of a Protestant-dominated federal government intervening in social and cultural life is anathema to you because it threatens your own autonomy within a world of religious freedom.
共同执行它，但并没有明确说明他们将如何做到这一点。地方当局通常对执行禁酒令并不真正感兴趣。他们对此并不在意。他们认为这行不通。所以这其中有这样一个因素。这让三K党很恼火，因为三K党非常支持禁酒。但众所周知，天主教徒不喜欢禁酒令。这并不是因为天主教徒特别喜欢喝酒。这是因为天主教徒不喜欢联邦政府监管道德生活的想法。显然他们不喜欢。他们就是这么说的。嗯，我认为显而易见的是，如果你是一名天主教徒，一个以新教为主导的联邦政府干预社会和文化生活的想法对你来说是令人厌恶的，因为它威胁到了你在宗教自由世界中的自主权。
But there must be lazy people who want to drink. Yeah, but there's loads of German Protestants who want to drink. One reason prohibition gets through, by the way, is because until the 1910s, German brewers had led the opposition to it. Protestant brewers. First World War happens so no one wants to listen to a German brewer. They're obviously bad guys. And so prohibition can get through. I mean, that's a little bit simplistic, but there's an element of it. Anyway, to the clan, prohibition is existential. Will these Catholics obey the law of the land or not? Will the constitution be upheld? Will our traditional American virtues prevail? Or will people flout the law and will Catholic bootleggers get their way? And a lot of historians
但肯定有懒人想喝酒。是的，但有很多德国新教徒想喝酒。顺便说一句，禁酒令得以通过的一个原因是，直到1910年代，德国酿酒商一直领导着反对禁酒令的运动。新教酿酒商。第一次世界大战爆发了，所以没人想听德国酿酒商的话。他们显然是坏人。所以禁酒令得以通过。我的意思是，这有点简单化了，但其中确实有这个因素。总之，对于三K党来说，禁酒令是关乎生存的问题。这些天主教徒会遵守国家法律吗？宪法会得到维护吗？我们传统的美国美德会占上风吗？还是人们会藐视法律，让天主教私酒贩子得逞？很多历史学家
actually think that prohibition is the real issue that gets the clan going. So there's a brilliant historian of the clan in Indiana, which was his biggest state called Lenin Moore. And he says he thinks this is the single biggest bond, uniting Klansmen, their commitment to prohibition. I mean, he gives us mad examples. In Seymour, Indiana, there was a huge burning cross and a sign beneath it that said, in honor of our savior who died to save the world, bootleggers, gamblers, law violators, beware, the eyes of the clan are watching you. They're kind of like an unbelievably militant and violent Salvation Army. Yes, I suppose.
实际上认为禁酒令是让三K党活跃起来的真正原因。印第安纳州有一位研究三K党的杰出历史学家，那是他们最大的州，名叫列宁·摩尔。他说他认为这是团结三K党成员的最大纽带，即他们对禁酒令的承诺。我的意思是，他给了我们一些疯狂的例子。在印第安纳州的西摩，有一个巨大的燃烧的十字架，下面有一块牌子写着：为了纪念为拯救世界而死的救世主，私酒贩子、赌徒、违法者，当心，三K党的眼睛在注视着你们。他们就像一支令人难以置信的激进且暴力的救世军。是的，我想是这样。
I mean, in some ways, yes, there would be a little crossover because the clan believe in enforcing, you know, moral austerity, I suppose. They will send volunteer groups to join cops in crackdowns on bootleggers and on speakeas and things, especially in states where there's already a lot of vigilantism like Oklahoma or Arkansas. And over time, the remit of these moral enforcers becomes wider and wider. I mean, actually, you know, the news that while we're making this show is dominated by Iran. Yeah, so they're like the morality police in Iran. That's exactly what they are.
我的意思是，在某些方面，是的，会有一些交叉，因为三K党相信执行，你知道，道德上的严苛，我想。他们会派遣志愿者团体加入警察的行列，打击私酒贩子和地下酒吧之类的地方，特别是在像俄克拉荷马州或阿肯色州这样已经有很多治安维持活动的州。随着时间的推移，这些道德执行者的职权范围变得越来越广。我的意思是，实际上，你知道，我们制作这个节目时的新闻被伊朗占据了。是的，所以他们就像伊朗的道德警察。他们正是那样的人。
Over time, groups of clansmen will not just enforce prohibition. They will target, and I quote, negligent parents, defiant children and unfaithful spouses. So there are lots of accounts in the early 1920s of Klansmen beating up husbands who've deserted their wives. So I'm going to assume from this that there are going to be loads of Klansmen who cheat on their wives. Because you're assuming they'll behave badly. I am assuming that, yes. You're not wrong. You're absolutely not wrong.
随着时间的推移，三K党成员团体将不仅仅是执行禁酒令。他们会针对，我引用一下，“玩忽职守的父母、反叛的孩子和不忠的配偶”。所以20世纪20年代初有很多关于三K党成员殴打抛弃妻子的丈夫的报道。所以我从这里推测，会有很多三K党成员欺骗他们的妻子。因为你假设他们会表现得很糟糕。我确实是这样假设的。你没说错。你绝对没说错。
And they've got a lot of that to come in the next episode. And there's some pretty, actually, some pretty awful stories of Klansmen, the sort of moral vigilantism. So in California, they kidnapped a doctor who was accused of when I called him. performing illegal operations on high school girls. Basically, he's an abortionist, I guess. They stripped him, they beat him, they hanged him till he passed out. Then they revived him and they beat him again with a rope and with a loaded gun. The most shocking example of this actually is a place called Mare Rouge in Louisiana in 1922.
在下一集中他们还有很多这样的内容。实际上，有一些关于三K党成员那种道德治安维持的相当可怕的故事。在加利福尼亚州，他们绑架了一名医生，他被指控——当我提到他时——对高中女生进行非法手术。基本上，我猜他是个堕胎医生。他们剥光了他的衣服，殴打他，把他吊起来直到他昏过去。然后他们让他苏醒，又用绳子和装了子弹的枪再次殴打他。这方面最令人震惊的例子实际上是1922年路易斯安那州一个叫马雷鲁日的地方。
There'd been weeks of fighting between the people of Mare Rouge, who were accused of being bootleggers and Klansmen from the next town along, which was called Bastrop. and the Klansman kidnapped five men from Meroge. They dragged them out their cars, they whipped them, then they tortured, castrated and murdered two of them and threw their bodies into a lake. And when the authorities looked into this,
马雷鲁日的人民和来自隔壁城镇巴斯特罗普的三K党成员之间已经进行了数周的战斗，马雷鲁日的人被指控为私酒贩子。三K党成员绑架了马雷鲁日的五个人。他们把他们从车里拖出来，鞭打他们，然后折磨、阉割并谋杀了其中两人，把他们的尸体扔进了湖里。当当局调查这件事时，
the culprits included the local sheriff, his deputies, the postmaster, the doctor, and even the district attorney. So again, the respectable people of the parish. But because the clan had infiltrated the local jury as well, none of them was ever convicted. So that's a sign of just how dark things can get. Anyway, let's get back to the overall narrative as we get into the final moments of the episode. So we're now in 1921. The Clark Tyler operation has been going for a year and it has been a colossal success. The clan has added hundreds of thousands of members, thanks to all these
罪犯包括当地警长、他的副手、邮政局长、医生，甚至地方检察官。所以，又是教区的体面人。但因为三K党也渗透到了当地的陪审团中，所以他们中没有人被定罪。这标志着事情可以变得多么黑暗。总之，让我们回到整体叙事，进入这一集的最后时刻。我们现在是在1921年。克拉克-泰勒行动已经进行了一年，取得了巨大的成功。三K党增加了数十万名成员，多亏了所有这些
techniques, exploiting anxiety about prohibition, going to Methodist sermons, basically recruiting masons, all of this stuff. The people, put at the top of suddenly very rich. So Simmons, this guy who was just a complete loser and a salesman and whatnot, has made the equivalent to probably $8 million in today's money. And the clan has bought him to recognize his role as the founder. They bought him a $33,000 home in Atlanta, which he called Clan Crest. That was the name of his house. But storm clouds are gathering. Because some people are getting very alarmed that the clan is out of control, that this sort of moral policing has gone too far. In September 1921, the New York world began a long-running series
技术，利用对禁酒令的焦虑，参加卫理公会的布道，基本上招募共济会成员，所有这些东西。放在顶层的人突然变得非常有钱。所以西蒙斯，这个家伙只是一个彻头彻尾的失败者和推销员之类的，已经赚到了相当于今天大约800万美元的钱。三K党买下他以承认他作为创始人的角色。他们为他在亚特兰大买了一栋价值33,000美元的房子，他称之为“三K党之巅”。那是他房子的名字。但风暴云正在聚集。因为有些人开始非常担心三K党已经失控，这种道德治安维持已经走得太远了。1921年9月，《纽约世界报》开始了一系列长期连载
exposing clan violence across the country, which was syndicated in other papers, and the reporters hoped that this would burst the clan's bubble. There were also rumours spreading about Clark and Mrs Tyler that they are, despite their sales genius, they are not quite living up to their own principles. So they had been found in bed by police in Atlanta, with the bottle of whiskey in a seedy sex hotel. Was this before they became? Before, yes, this story comes out. And they'd given false names.
揭露全国各地的三K党暴力事件，这些报道在其他报纸上联合刊登，记者们希望这能戳破三K党的泡沫。还有关于克拉克和泰勒夫人的传言流传，说他们尽管有销售天赋，但并没有完全遵守他们自己的原则。所以他们被亚特兰大的警察发现睡在床上，带着一瓶威士忌，在一家肮脏的性爱旅馆里。这是在他们成为（领导人）之前吗？之前，是的，这个故事传出来了。他们还用了假名字。
And they were fined $5 each for disorderly conduct. Now, it's just a small thing. But the bottle of whiskey in bed together in the seedy hotel is bad. That's not Protestant values. But a very familiar story. Yeah, a very familiar story. I mean, that's, what's his name? Jim Backer.
他们因扰乱治安各被罚款5美元。现在，这只是一件小事。但在肮脏的旅馆里一起躺在床上，带着一瓶威士忌，这很糟糕。那不是新教价值观。但这是一个非常熟悉的故事。是的，一个非常熟悉的故事。我的意思是，那是，他叫什么名字？吉姆·贝克。
Yes. And Tammy Faye Backer. It's what I assume all televangelists are doing. I mean, I'd be disappointed if they weren't. And then eventually, a month or so after the New York World series, Congress held hearings on the clan, the House Rules Committee, and they got Simmons to take the stand. And Simmons actually cut a very melodramatic figure.
是的。还有塔米·菲·贝克。我假设所有的电视布道家都在做这些事。我的意思是，如果他们不这样做，我会感到失望的。然后最终，在《纽约世界报》系列报道一个月左右后，国会就三K党举行了听证会，众议院规则委员会，他们让西蒙斯出庭作证。西蒙斯实际上表现得非常戏剧化。
He wore deliberately old-fashioned clothes, a sort of frock coat and a stiff collar. And he basically posed as the incarnation of the Old South. I'm a southern gentleman and I formed this association to honor my forefathers. So like Colonel Sanders. Exactly. The KFC guy. Yes, there's a lot of that, actually.
他故意穿了老式的衣服，一种长礼服和硬领。他基本上把自己塑造成旧南方的化身。我是一位南方绅士，我成立这个协会是为了纪念我的祖先。就像桑德斯上校一样。正是如此。肯德基的那个人。是的，实际上有很多这样的情况。
Simmons says, sure, we have a few bad apples, but we are God-fearing, honest Americans and all this. And at the climax of the hearings, he made him out dramatically, raised his hand to the heavens and he called on God to forgive those who have persecuted the clan. And then he collapsed in apparent exhaustion. Anyway, the hearings ended. and the House Rules Committee agreed that the clan had no case to answer. So they got away with it, Scott Free. And actually all of this was brilliant publicity for the clan. Even the series in the new world about clan atrocities,
西蒙斯说，当然，我们有一些害群之马，但我们是敬畏上帝、诚实的美国人等等。在听证会的高潮，他戏剧性地伸出手向天空，呼吁上帝宽恕那些迫害三K党的人。然后他似乎精疲力竭地倒下了。总之，听证会结束了。众议院规则委员会同意三K党没有需要回答的指控。所以他们逍遥法外了。实际上，所有这些对三K党来说都是绝佳的宣传。即使是《纽约世界报》关于三K党暴行的系列报道，
people just thought, God, this sounds so exciting. This group, they're riding around the countryside, attacking errant husbands, you know, intimidating Catholic, shouting about prohibition. This sounds great. And in the next few weeks, there are 100,000 new applications to join, supposedly every week. And the clan started to spread even further. you know, out of its base
人们只是想，天哪，这听起来太刺激了。这个组织，他们在乡间骑行，攻击行为不端的丈夫，你知道，恐吓天主教徒，大喊禁酒令。这听起来很棒。在接下来的几周里，据说每周都有10万份新的加入申请。三K党开始进一步蔓延，
into Colorado and Oregon and all these places. And then it grew all the way through 1920, which was its annas Mirabilis. And that autumn, it made its debut really as a political force. So it worked for, it basically endorsed candidates for governor
进入科罗拉多州、俄勒冈州和所有这些地方。然后它在整个1920年持续增长，那是它的“奇迹之年”。那年秋天，它真正作为一种政治力量首次亮相。所以它为，它基本上支持了州长候选人
in Georgia, Alabama and California. And it claimed that it had elected no fewer than 75 members of the US House of Representatives. And actually, I don't think that's really an exaggeration. You know, the clan, it's got a lot of members, it's got a lot of influence, and if it endorses you, you know, you can do really well. So, the couple of examples of this.
在佐治亚州、阿拉巴马州和加利福尼亚州。它声称它选出了不少于75名美国众议院议员。实际上，我不认为这真的是夸张。你知道，三K党，它有很多成员，它有很多影响力，如果它支持你，你知道，你可以做得非常好。所以，这里有几个例子。
And they're at different ends of the country. That's the incredible thing. So one of them is in Oregon. Oregon was very white, very Protestant. You know, it's the far sort of northwestern corner of America. Of clan-endorsed candidates all but won, won their seats in the Oregon Senate. They won a virtual majority in the Oregon House. the Klan candidate, a man who boasted in his campaign literature,
它们位于国家的两端。这是令人难以置信的事情。所以其中一个在俄勒冈州。俄勒冈州非常白人，非常新教。你知道，它是美国西北部的远角。三K党支持的候选人几乎赢得了俄勒冈州参议院的所有席位。他们在俄勒冈州众议院赢得了事实上的多数席位。三K党候选人，一个在他的竞选宣传册中吹嘘的人，
every one of my ancestors has been a Protestant for 300 years. This guy wins the governorship in Oregon. And on top of all that, the Klan pushed through a referendum to ban Catholic schools in the state of Oregon. Now, this measure was later thrown out by the courts. It was unconstitutional. But what a symbol of the Klan's clout in this state. in a state where there are basically no African-Americans, there are no Jews,
“我的每一位祖先都是新教徒，已经有300年了。”这个家伙赢得了俄勒冈州的州长职位。最重要的是，三K党推动了一项禁止俄勒冈州天主教学校的全民公投。现在，这项措施后来被法院驳回了。它是违宪的。但这是三K党在这个州影响力的象征。在一个基本上没有非裔美国人、没有犹太人的州，
but the anxieties about these groups as such that the clan has this incredible clout. And then let's go to the other extreme, Texas, right, but as far from Oregon as you can get. Texas, the clan had been established in 1920. It had been established really to sort of lost cause of the Confederacy group. This is the genius of the clan. They tick different boxes in different states. So in Texas, Simmons went to the annual meeting of the United Confederate Veterans, and he signed everybody up. He said, this is an organization that will commemorate the holy and chivalric achievements of our fathers.
但对这些群体的焦虑使得三K党拥有这种令人难以置信的影响力。然后让我们去另一个极端，德克萨斯州，对，但离俄勒冈州尽可能远。德克萨斯州，三K党成立于1920年。它实际上是为了某种邦联的“迷途事业”团体而建立的。这就是三K党的天才之处。他们在不同的州勾选不同的框。所以在德克萨斯州，西蒙斯参加了联合邦联退伍军人年度会议，他让每个人都加入了。他说，这是一个将纪念我们祖先神圣和骑士精神成就的组织。
And he got loads of really respectable people, as one historian puts it, a who's who of business, the professions, and patriotism. And then once they've got the top people, they worked on the rest. They got a new guy's grand goblin, who was called inevitably George B. Kimbrough, Jr. who was an ice cream salesman from Houston. That's possibly the most American moments so far in the series. It is on the so many American moments. And this guy, George B. Kimbrough Jr., was brilliant at recruiting people. He would go to evangelical churches and he'd sign up the whole congregation in one go.
他招募了大量非常体面的人，正如一位历史学家所说，是商业、专业和爱国主义的名人录。然后一旦他们有了顶层的人，他们就开始做其余人的工作。他们得到了一个新家伙作为大妖精，不可避免地叫乔治·B·金布罗，小，他是一个来自休斯顿的冰淇淋推销员。这可能是该系列中迄今为止最美国化的时刻。确实有很多美国时刻。这个家伙，乔治·B·金布罗，小，在招募人方面非常出色。他会去福音派教堂，一次性签下整个会众。
So by 1922, there are 200,000 Klansmen in Texas. And actually, in some respects, it's a perfectly ordinary fraternal organization. So the historian Thomas Pigram gives the story of Hope Cottage. Dallas, which was a nursery and adoption center for abandoned babies. And it had fallen into disrepair. And the Dallas branch of the clan raised $85,000 to restore it. And they presented it as a gift to the city of Dallas at the Texas State Fair. And I googled it.
所以到1922年，德克萨斯州有20万名三K党成员。实际上，在某些方面，它是一个完全普通的兄弟会组织。所以历史学家托马斯·皮格拉姆讲述了“希望小屋”的故事。达拉斯，这是一个为被遗弃婴儿设立的托儿所和收养中心。它已经年久失修。三K党达拉斯分部筹集了85,000美元来修复它。他们在德克萨斯州博览会上把它作为礼物送给了达拉斯市。我谷歌了一下。
It's still going today. This, you know, basically a nursery and a center for mothers and babies and all of this kind of thing called Hope Cottage. I have to say their website doesn't make a huge amount of the, um, It's origins. Yeah, and I don't think the clan would be very pleased by the way that the, because it looks a lovely organisation, very diverse, very multicultural, you know, lovely place.
它今天还在运营。这个，你知道，基本上是一个托儿所和母亲与婴儿中心，以及所有这类东西，叫“希望小屋”。我必须说他们的网站并没有过多地强调它的起源。是的，我不认为三K党会很高兴，因为，因为它看起来是一个可爱的组织，非常多样化，非常多元文化，你知道，可爱的地方。
I commend it to the listeners, but basically it was the clan that saved it. So there's that side of the clan. And because of its respectability, it does really well politically in Texas. In November 1922, the clan not only swept the Texas state legislature, but they elected their first avowed Klansman as a US senator, who was a guy called Earl Mayfield, a Democrat, a fan of prohibition. They endorsed him as a native-born white Protestant Gentile. The issue in the election in that November was the clan, and he won,
我向听众推荐它，但基本上是三K党拯救了它。所以三K党有那一面。而且由于它的体面，它在德克萨斯州的政治上做得非常好。1922年11月，三K党不仅横扫了德克萨斯州立法机构，而且他们选出了他们的第一位公开的三K党成员作为美国参议员，他是一个叫厄尔·梅菲尔德的家伙，民主党人，禁酒令的粉丝。他们支持他作为本土出生的白人新教徒外邦人。那年11月选举的问题是三K党，他赢了，
and he went off to the Senate. But that respectability is not the whole picture of the clan in Texas. Historically, Texas is a very violent state, and the local clan reflects it in fact in few states is the local clan so devoted to vigilantism. And there are some terrible, terrible stories. There's a black guy who was kidnapped in Dallas and is branded in acid on his forehead with the letters KKK. There's a black dentist who is kidnapped in Houston and flogged within an inch of his life. There are men who are whipped for leaving their wives.
他去了参议院。但那种体面并不是德克萨斯州三K党的全部。从历史上看，德克萨斯州是一个非常暴力的州，当地的三K党反映了这一点，事实上，很少有州的三K党如此致力于治安维持。有一些非常、非常可怕的故事。有一个黑人被绑架在达拉斯，前额被酸液烙上了KKK的字母。有一个黑人牙医在休斯顿被绑架，被鞭打得只剩半条命。有男人因为抛弃妻子而被鞭打。
There are lawyers who are beaten for representing black clients. Dallas is probably the worst place. So there was a place by the river in Dallas, which was known as the whipping meadow, where the clan would take people and whip them en masse. So at one point, there are claims that they've flogged 68 people in one, you know, in a couple of months or something. There are claims that the clan is organising, taring and feathering parties, or whipping bees. You know how they have spelling bees in America?
有律师因为代表黑人客户而被殴打。达拉斯可能是最糟糕的地方。达拉斯河边有一个地方，被称为“鞭打草甸”，三K党会把人带到那里集体鞭打。所以有一次，有人声称他们在几个月内鞭打了68人。有人声称三K党正在组织焦油和羽毛派对，或者鞭打聚会。你知道美国有拼写比赛吗？
They will have whipping bees. I mean, if they're whipping, if they're tiring and feathering people, I mean, that's quite solid evidence, I would say. It's not that simple, though. Because you would think to be police records, right? Court records. Well, there'd be people walking around with, you know, tar and feathers. Well, we'll get on to this act. Because a lot of this, you see, is covered up.
他们会有鞭打比赛。我的意思是，如果他们在对人涂焦油和羽毛，我的意思是，那是非常确凿的证据，我会说。不过没那么简单。因为你认为会有警察记录，对吧？法庭记录。好吧，会有人们走来走去，你知道，带着焦油和羽毛。好吧，我们会谈到这个行为。因为你看，这其中很多都被掩盖了。
It's covered up by the authorities because they're clansmen themselves. Judges, sheriffs, cops, jurymen, all of these kinds of things. So I'll give you an example. This is what we'll end the episode with. Place called Goose Creek, which was an oil town just across the bay from Houston. There was one evening in January 1923, and we're in one house, and a woman, the lady who lives there lives with her children. She's called Mrs. Harrison.
它被当局掩盖了，因为他们自己就是三K党成员。法官、警长、警察、陪审员，所有这些类型的人。所以我给你举个例子。这就是我们结束这一集的地方。一个叫鹅溪的地方，那是休斯顿海湾对面的一座石油小镇。那是1923年1月的一个晚上，我们在一个房子里，一个女人，住在那里的女士和她的孩子们住在一起。她叫哈里森夫人。
She's recently separated from her husband, and she's ill in bed. She's just an ordinary, you know, white Protestant housewife. And she's upstairs in bed. And a neighbour of hers called Mr. Armand has brought her some fruit. So he's up with her talking to her, giving her the fruit, and her children are downstairs playing with the neighbour's children who've come round. And the door crashes open and a dozen Klansmen burst in. Some of them are dressed.
她最近和丈夫分居了，病倒在床上。她只是一个普通的，你知道，白人新教徒家庭主妇。她在楼上床上。她的一个邻居叫阿曼德先生，给她带了一些水果。所以他在楼上和她说话，给她水果，她的孩子们在楼下和过来玩耍的邻居的孩子们一起玩。门被撞开了，一打三K党成员冲了进来。他们中的一些人穿着衣服。
They're not all dressed in robes. Some of them are dressed as clowns or in women's clothing. Mrs. Harrison and Mr. Armand were dragged outside at gunpoint. The children are kind of screaming and whatnot. The clownsmen took them away and they scourged them. They flogged them both. Then they hacked off her hair with a knife right down to the scalp. So a scalp is kind of bleeding.
他们并不都穿着长袍。他们中的一些人打扮成小丑或穿着女装。哈里森夫人和阿曼德先生被用枪指着拖到外面。孩子们在尖叫之类的。小丑们把他们带走并鞭打了他们。他们鞭打了他们两个。然后他们用刀把她的头发割掉，一直割到头皮。所以头皮在流血。
And they then got a load of crude oil. It's an oil town, remember. And they poured it over his open wounds. Oh, God. And you said, oh, well, either we know or we don't. Well, in this case, neither of them would talk to the police. They didn't die, but they're obviously very badly injured, but they won't talk to the police. And just to be clear, they weren't having an affair.
然后他们弄了一堆原油。记住，这是一个石油小镇。他们把它倒在他敞开的伤口上。天哪。你说，哦，好吧，要么我们知道，要么我们不知道。好吧，在这种情况下，他们两个都不愿和警察说话。他们没有死，但显然受了重伤，但他们不会和警察说话。顺便说一句，他们没有外遇。
He'd just come around because he was a nice guy and giving fruit. No one knows. Okay. But obviously, the assumption is that the clan thought they were having an affair. Mrs. Harrison's daughter, who was seven, who had seen this, told the county sheriff what had happened. And he took it to the district judge, and he sent in investigating. from Houston and convened a grand jury. And when they looked into it, the outsiders,
他只是过来，因为他是个好人，送水果。没人知道。好吧。但显然，假设是三K党认为他们有外遇。哈里森夫人的女儿，七岁，目睹了这一切，告诉了县警长发生了什么。他把它带给地方法官，他派人去调查。来自休斯顿，并召集了大陪审团。当他们调查时，外来者，
they were horrified by what they found because it turned out that for the last 18 months, clan vigilantes had conducted, I mean, genuinely a kind of reign of terror in this small town, Goose Creek. The local people had been completely cowered into submission. The clan had kidnapped and beaten and scourged and whipped at least 20 people in this small town
他们对所发现的情况感到震惊，因为事实证明，在过去的18个月里，三K党治安维持者在鹅溪这个小镇上进行了，我的意思是，真正的一种恐怖统治。当地人完全被吓得屈服了。三K党在这个小镇绑架、殴打、鞭打了至少20人
because of alleged immorality. because they defended the clan in some way. What happens to the Klansmen? Are they convicted? I think some of them are convicted, yeah, because there's a huge hullabaloo about it. But it takes an enormous effort by external authorities to basically break the conspiracy of silence around this. So obviously the question with the clan is, which is the true face of it? Is it the respectable people who are donating to rescue the children's home?
因为所谓的“不道德”。因为他们以某种方式为三K党辩护。三K党成员发生了什么？他们被定罪了吗？我想他们中的一些人被定罪了，是的，因为对此有巨大的骚动。但外部当局需要付出巨大的努力才能基本上打破围绕此事的沉默阴谋。所以显然关于三K党的问题是，哪一个是它的真面目？是那些捐款拯救儿童之家的体面人吗？
Or is it the reign of terror and the pouring of crude oil over open wounds? and that question becomes more and more urgent the larger the clan becomes because as we enter 1923 it is growing all the time its momentum seems unstoppable and a presidential election is fast approaching in 1924 in which the clan is determined that it will play the part of Kingmaker. So next time in the final episode of this series we'll be looking at the clan and it's rise and rise in the industrial Midwest
还是恐怖统治和把原油倒在敞开的伤口上？随着三K党变得越来越大，这个问题变得越来越紧迫，因为当我们进入1923年时，它一直在增长，它的势头似乎不可阻挡，1924年的总统选举即将来临，三K党决心在其中扮演“造王者”的角色。所以下次，在本系列的最后一集中，我们将看看三K党及其在工业中西部的崛起，
the struggle for control of the national organization of the clan, and we will be recounting one of the strangest and most tragic murder scandals that we've ever done on The Rest is History. So club members can hear that final episode in this series on the Ku Klux Klan right now. And if you're not a member and you'd like to be, then go to the rest is history.com. Otherwise, we will be back with you on Thursday. Thank you, Dominic. Bye-bye. Goodbye.
争夺三K党全国组织的控制权，我们将讲述我们在《历史的其余部分》中做过的最奇怪、最悲惨的谋杀丑闻之一。所以俱乐部成员现在就可以听到关于三K党的这个系列的最后一集。如果你不是会员，想成为会员，那么去therestishistory.com。否则，我们周四会回来。谢谢你，多米尼克。再见。再见。
Getting ready for a game means being ready for anything. Like packing a spare stick. I like to be prepared. That's why I remember, 988, Canada's Suicide Crisis Hubline. It's good to know, just in case. Anyone can call or text for free confidential support from a train responder anytime. 988 Suicide Crisis Helpline is funded by the government in Canada. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
为比赛做准备意味着为任何事情做好准备。比如带一根备用球杆。我喜欢有备无患。这就是为什么我记得988，加拿大的自杀危机求助热线。很高兴知道，以防万一。任何人都可以随时拨打或发短信，从训练有素的响应者那里获得免费的保密支持。988自杀危机求助热线由加拿大政府资助。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。